So I'm I'm sure you get this all the
time when you speak about Iran. They're
going to say you're Shia, you're Sunni,
you're Hanafi, you're Sufi, you're a
Salafi. What are you?
>> I'm a Muslim.
>> Alhamdulillah.
>> You were talking about the shadowbanned
from social media. When were you
shadowbanned by the government? Because
they always say that you got banned by
the Indian government.
>> Indian government got banned in 2016.
>> So
>> and the shadowban came after that.
>> So you were banned from India. You're
not allowed to go to India anymore.
>> No, I can go but I can't come out.
They'll welcome me if I go. They'll
they'll welcome me to come in, but they
won't allow me to go out.
>> But what is their reason?
>> The reason basically is because of my
popularity.
>> Is that what they
>> It's not because I'm popular only in
Muslims. That's not a problem with
Hindus.
>> I'm popular among the non-Muslims and
the vote bank is trying to bring
division between Hindu and Muslim and my
talks get unity between Hindu, Muslim.
>> They say uh Jesus says I am the way, the
truth and the
>> correct. This is from Gospel of John
chapter 14 verse number six. Okay. The
messenger at that time was the truth,
the way and the life. No man came to God
but through the messenger. So at the
time of Moses, Moses peace be upon him
was the way, the truth and the life. No
man came to God but through Moses. At
the time of Jesus Christ peace be upon
him. Jesus was the way, the truth and
the life. No man came to God but through
Jesus peace be upon him. So he's the way
and the truth. That doesn't make him
God. That makes him a person of God.
Makes him a messenger of God.
>> Mhm. Does your dean get corrupted
communicating with these people? Because
right now this is a a form of hydra in a
way going to Malaysia and this and I'm
way more at peace around the Muslims but
I'm from New York and there's physical
attacks there's mental attacks there's
people constant there's evil eye and you
get pulled away from the dean and it's
it's it's your fault but the difference
between you know Ramadan when you're in
Medina and Mecca around the believers
and then back home in the land of the
disbelievers it's very it's the polar
opposites and you having dealt with all
these quote, "How do you protect your IM
from the people that want to destroy
it?"
>> Yeah, the Malcolm X autobiography.
Absolutely. Which I'm sure you've read.
>> Of course, I know many.
>> Okay.
>> I know about him.
>> And there's so much that I want to ask
about your story and
>> getting into your life. They were
calling you the original Di, you know,
the the OG in a way, if we're going to
use Warner's terminology. So, man, where
to begin? Maybe
>> well I mean if you don't mind me asking
how did your da journey begin? Like how
what inspired you uh to speak this the
truth in in a land full of paganism?
Actually uh my childhood I was a normal
practicing Muslim
>> normal but when I met Shik Ahmed Dab
>> after I met him I changed from a doctor
of body to doctor of soul
>> so actually my parents especially my
mother wanted me to become a heart
specialist doctor I'm from family of
doctor my father is a doctor my brother
is a doctor my father is a psychiatrist
>> so while I was in the medical college
that time I met Shik Ahmed
>> and after I met him I changed from a
doctor of body Doctor of soul.
>> So it's a doctor of the body. Now you
know the doctor of the soul.
>> So my mother wanted to me to become like
someone like Dr. Chris Bernard. If you
know Dr. Chris Bernard is the first
heart specialist who did the heart
transplantation in the human being.
>> So she wanted me to be somewhat like
him. So when I met Shik Ahmed Dan and I
started doing dava. So I asked my mother
do you want me to become like shake
zidad or Dr. Krisa? She said both. But
after a few years in the field of dava
and mashallah Allah mashallah gave her
success and all. Alhamdulillah. Then she
said that I would sacrifice a thousand
Dr. Kris Banana for one shake Ahmed.
Alhamdulillah. So that's how my journey
started.
>> So then I became then I gave up my
medical profession.
>> Well, in your specialty was what
exactly?
>> General medicine.
>> And how long since you quit or left?
>> I met Shik Dad in my medical college. So
when I finished my medical college, I
practiced very little because my father
had a roaring practice. Mhm.
>> So I practice very little maybe less
than a year and then I started managing
a pathological you know one of our
pathological laboratory centers I
managed it. So initially it was 2 hours
dhava rest medical then it was half
50/50 then two hours medical practice
remaining da then a full-time D. So
hardly within a span of couple of years
I became a full-time D. So then my
parent dedicated me full time for the
cause of DA and that's how we started a
small organization and alhamdulillah it
became the largest private Muslim da
organization in the world
>> and because of the success the Indian
government didn't really like the
success that many non-Muslim came for my
talks so that they didn't do hijra in
so I left my country and then I came to
Malaysia.
>> What do you think it was that made you
guys so successful at what you guys do?
>> Nothing of our own. It is and I sometime
wonder why people come for my talk. So
it is mainly Allah's help like you know
if Allah is really is out to help you
and Allah says in the Quran in surah
Iran 3:60 if Allah helps you none can
overcome you. If Allah forsakes you who
is there then who can help you. So put
your trust in Allah.
>> Mhm. And the best example I mean my son
mashallah if you see my childhood
compared to his childhood the training
he got for Islam is thousand times
better than me thousand times more than
thousand times
>> Arabic langu better English but Allah
support is most important he's known but
I tell him that unless Allah doesn't
support you his masters in Islam his PhD
so in terms of qualification in terms of
uh training training maybe thousands of
times better than me
>> but yet it is Allah's help that that
that gives you success. It is not your
>> intelligence or your or your knowledge.
Of course the more you strive in the way
of Allah, Allah helps you. So striving
is from your side and then the rest you
leave to Allah.
>> Your professions are very different but
also very similar in some ways. So as a
doctor it's like you're helping people
in this life.
>> Correct.
>> But as a diet you're helping them in the
next life.
>> Correct. So the reason I became a doctor
was mainly to help humanity. And before
I met Shik Ahmed Dad, I thought doctor
is the best profession to serve
humanity. It is a good profession. But
when I met Shik Datad and when I when I
read the Quran more deeply as Allah says
in chapter 41:33, Allah says,
"Who is better in speed than one who
invites to the way of thy lord? Works
righteousness and sees I'm a Muslim." So
according to Allah subhanaa tala in the
Quran the best profession is a di
there's no better profession than person
spreading the dean of Allah. So that's
the reason I changed from a doctor of
body to a doctor of
>> so the most important profession is a di
>> yes the highest profession in Islam that
that includes that can take closer to
Allah
>> and also of course then is there there
are many other but is the best
>> so how have you noticed the da scene or
dawa in general shift since you started
you've been doing it for a long time and
they say that you're the original I
think especially utilizing social media
in the way that it's used now.
>> I think probably pioneered a lot of the
same outlook that people have now
what do you think is going well and what
do you think needs work on?
>> Previously as I told I was inspired by
Shik Ahmed. So maybe about 40 years ago
or 30 years back the number one D was
shik Ahmed Dad.
>> Shake who?
>> Shik Ahmed he's from South Africa.
>> They were telling me about this Ahmed.
So he's a teacher. So when he was there
he was undisputed number one there was
no one close to him the champion
>> and he started making his talks on video
and distributing the video all over the
world so his dharma mini was by by video
that's how he became famous and he got
the king fatal award that was in the
late 80s and '90s and that time I met
him and I was inspired by him
>> and of course at the time of sheik Ahmed
there was no social media so when social
media came we we even utilized social
media And we started our own satellite
channel TV. So when we saw the Islamic
>> beach peace TV
>> peace TV is the peace TV.
>> Peace.
>> Peace TV is the largest religious
channel in the world in terms of number
of views.
>> Mhm.
>> So when we started we saw that the
quality was very low. So I always
believe that we should have the best of
quality. So when we started Peach TV we
used the best cameras for the satellite
industry. In 2005 we started the
channel. We started English first then
went on to Udu, Bangla, Chinese. English
reached a viewership of 100 million in a
few years.
>> Mhm.
>> Then Udu had 80 million, Bangla had 50
million, Chinese 20 more. Put together
200 to 50 million viewership.
>> And how many languages you speak?
>> I speak fluently and you can say three
words in that
>> udu, English, Arabic.
>> Udu, English, Arabic. I know but not
that well. Not that big of a talk.
>> Okay.
>> So English, udu, Hindi.
>> And this is around what year? 2005 2006
>> about the channel TV started in 2006 it
was launched 2005 was the test run
>> that's when YouTube just was created
>> yes
>> so that's how first we came on YouTube
we started dav on the on the cable TVs
>> on cable TV
>> cable TV so very popular then we started
satellite channel then of course we on
social media
>> so in social media of course when there
was no much of uh shadow banning so my
Facebook reached about 25 million
followers
But there's a shadow ban. So it has
stopped increasing. It increased
previously increased about 5 million a
year.
>> A shadow ban when was this?
>> About 10 years back.
>> There were shadow bans back then.
>> Yes, it started that. It just started.
>> Okay.
>> And if the government is against it. So
2016 it started 1718. Now it's very
high. So now now maybe in a year it
increase by 100,000 only. Previously 5
million a year. It was it was my
Facebook was banned by the by the
government in 2012. We started a new
thing Facebook
>> Indian government banning your Facebook
recent
>> because of the popularity there are many
non-Muslims come for my talk
>> I know
>> and there are
>> especially Hindus
>> thousands of Hindus that come for my
talk and they accept Islam
>> so they say what we did not learn in 40
years of our life we we hear Dr.
in two hours and we understand the
religion better and I believe in talking
about similarity rather than
differences. I don't believe in winning
the match. I don't believe in defeating
the opponent. I believe in winning him
over.
>> That's what the Quran says in Surah
Fasil chapter 41:34 that repel evil with
good. You never know they'll become your
friend who's the enemy. So in that way
mashallah uh the people of India took my
talks very well. We had large audiences.
It started with a thousand then reached
to 100,000 and then more than a million
live. The largest gathering is a million
people live in one venue which is the
largest gathering in the world for any
religious speaker.
>> Wow.
>> In one city.
>> So and then on the satellite there are
100 million people watching. So that's
how it spread. But when the social
there's a free social media and there is
a paid social media. In free social
media we add their mercy. We cannot
speak what you want to speak. If you
speak what they don't like they'll ban
you. They'll stop your page. So that's
how we learned then we started not
saying everything what we wanted to say.
>> Yeah.
>> So being limited. So then the Facebook
got banned in 2012. We started in 2013.
Every year 45 million by 17 it addition
about 18 million
>> and then they would ban another one
>> and then there's the shadow ban now.
>> Okay.
>> Because we haven't broken the rules per
se,
>> right?
>> But they don't like we spreading Islam.
>> So yeah, you really are the the OG.
That's what we say in America ter cuz
all this sounds familiar to everything
that we go through now. The matrix
really did attack you first. What was
the reason that Facebook banned you
originally? Did because they can't just
>> No, they haven't banned me. No, first
first time it was in 2012 when the
Indian government complained on this
post something about uh Hinduism and
they made a protest about that.
>> Yeah.
>> So they took down my page. So then we
were more careful. We said let's do
because the Indian government all over
the world the maximum social media is in
India.
>> The maximum Facebook followers are in
India. Maximum YouTube in India. So
India has the largest follower because
Because China does not allow Facebook
and YouTube freely.
>> Mhm.
>> So China is the second largest
population. So maximum number of
Facebook users is not America. It is
India. So India is very powerful. It can
control YouTube you know Facebook a lot.
So so YouTube is completely banned in
India of mine. But the other people can
access it by changing the location. So
YouTube has so YouTube only has reached
4 and a half million.
>> I think YouTube is now on in in India.
It's available now. No, no, it is the
largest followers of YouTube is India.
>> Yeah, T-Series, but they for a while
they weren't
>> almost almost all the popular platforms,
social media. The largest followers are
in India. Number one,
>> there's a lot of you
>> or whether it be Facebook, whether it be
WhatsApp, whether it be YouTube, whether
it be all all most of them.
>> Because China doesn't allow this and
India has the largest population.
>> Mhm.
>> So because of that, they have a lot of
control. So then we should be careful
what we speak. So my Instagram reaches 1
to 3 million, then again gets pulled
down. Again, we start again, get pulled
down. Mhm.
>> So now we are there on the Facebook they
haven't banned my page but there's a
shadow banning.
>> Mhm.
>> But one thing good is that because we
have no copyrights when we release on
the YouTube. Previously every used to be
few hundred thousand now it's only few
thousand but people copy and they post
on their media. So the reach is there.
>> So do you mind when people do that or
you like
>> we encourage that? We encourage
>> I agree. I think that's the best
>> because we I don't make a single penny
from any of my Islamic activities
neither any of my social media. It's all
free. We don't believe in anyone
charging for my talks. So anyone calls
me and they charge a ticket, I don't go
to that talk. I said that it's not our
you know
>> it's not prohibited. If someone charges
>> right
>> but it's not preferable. It's not
mustach.
>> Okay.
>> It's not preferable. So we believe that
we should spread the message of the
dean. So people like you know they offer
me we will charge ticket and we'll pay.
I said no I don't need Allah has given
me. There are people offering me a
million dollar for one lecture they will
charge. I said no I'm happy with what
I'm earning and earning more than that
and we happy with that and we live a
simple life. We believe that we should
live a simple life so that no one can
pressurize you and give maximum of your
earning in charity
because we are in this life for the
hereafter. So that's why people are
shocked when they come oh it's such a
small apartment it's a big apartment
what's wrong in it. So we believe that
you should make your needs very less and
my son was you know he wanted to so I
told you you want to drive the car that
come to Dubai to my friend's house and I
made him drive almost all models of car
whether Ferrari Lamborghini drive but we
have a Toyota we can afford
>> roles Allah has given us that wealth but
we believe in giving charity
>> right
>> majority what you earn we have a
business where we s a luxury car and we
had all the cars we owned all the cars
but we didn't use it we had Maybag
Lamborghini, Bentley, you name the cars.
>> Let's go. Let's go.
>> We own it. We own it. But then we are
doing that for business.
>> Okay.
>> But we never travel in that car.
>> Uhhuh.
>> Okay. Test drive we did. For me, I
bought a Camry car there. So when I go
to Katar, I have a Camry car which I
bought for me. I travel in that.
>> A Camry.
>> A Camry. You can drive it. A Camry,
which is
>> Camry works. Gets from point A to point
B.
>> Sorry. Yes. No. No. Of course. It does.
>> It's a good car.
>> It's comfortable. It works.
>> And then so so we are doing for
business. So any D that comes to katar
we give them complimentary or may back
roll complimentary so that we get some
sab up for that but we believe that a
person so I tell my son that when you do
business make Allah your business
partner
>> and when you make Allah your business
partner you cannot make him a small
partner you have to make him minimum 51%
partner so I told my son in 1920 2022 in
charge business that minimum 51% of your
profit
>> every year you should give in charity
minimum you can give more
>> 51%
>> for him not for me it's much more I'm a
veteran So mind is a very high number.
>> So you have to give 51% minimum. So
whatever you own minimum 51% you start
and then you can increase what you want
to increase after that.
>> Mhm.
>> So alhamdulillah. So we believe that we
are in this world as a test for the
hereafter.
And you should not run after money.
Money should run after you and money is
not everything you know. So so Allah
test you. So in India when we were there
I used to pray to Allah every day that
let my life and wealth be sacrificed for
Allah. So when we did hijra when I left
India in 20 2016 we had to leave all our
behind large number big amount you know
tens of hund00 million we left it we
were zero we started again Allah give us
again
>> so I spend less than 10% of my time in
business maybe less than 1 hour a day
for managing my business
>> after the madai so I spend more than 10
hours in dawa in a day and other things
are there so alhamdulillah Allah has
blessed us but yet we kept our life
should be simple and give more charity
Allah test with you Allah test
So if you don't have love with money so
whether you make profit or don't make
profit doesn't for me for me and my wife
it takes me $500 a month to survive
including the guest not for my for dava
when I go I pay for my ticket that's
expensive but for my life for me and my
wife one one month I require $500 only
for my everything
>> $500 yes not love activities not buying
my camera is very expensive our PTV
cameras are the most expensive in the
world one camera cost $300,000 one
camera.
>> It's a Red camera.
>> Red is a very cheap camera. We have the
Sony Venus 2 original lens. The Red
camera is very cheap. Red camera is a
performance. They're very cheap. Very
cheap.
>> The more expensive are the lens. So for
a PTV first, we used to use the best
cameras for the broadcast industry. In
2015, we changed our strategy because
when we use the best camera for the
broadcast industry, it will remain on
top for four five years. That's it.
>> After that, it gets obsolete or it gets
weak, you know. So the programs of Shik
Ahmed Gita shot in 1995 I cannot use it
on PTV. So I'm spending millions of
dollars to upgrade it yet it's poor
quality.
>> So then in 2015 we started using film
cameras.
>> Now film cameras are 10 times more
expensive than the broadcast cameras.
>> Right?
>> So when we start using film cameras and
we purchased at one shot 18 film
cameras. Japan was shocked. Sony who's
purchasing the no one in the world who
has purchased film cameras because when
you shoot a film you have one camera and
you look into the lens. If it's a fight
sequence, there may be three four
cameras. So we purchased 18 cameras
together and each one costing quart
million dollar that time and then came
the confiscated cameras. Now we have
better cameras each costing about
$300,000. But those cameras of course
they require specialized things use. So
when we shoot a program which has
100,000 people or 500,000 people these
cameras it will remain inshallah for 100
years. So we shoot on 8K then we
downgrade it to HD and show on PTV. So
for YouTube social media we use a very
low quality less than 1% of the original
quality but the original we keep it safe
on LTO's because the same camera what
you use for the satellite the good
cameras will be in the market max 5 6
years not more than that so the film
cameras we shoot we store it on a high
quality and we downgrade it for our
channel
>> and for social media
>> you know your stuff so you know every
aspect of dawa from what the Wikipedia
it's all about comparative theology And
here you are like administration and of
course of course we are we had a we had
a staff of more than 500 full-time paid
employees in Bombay. So we were the
largest mashallah private Muslim da
organization in the world in terms of
number of people working in the terms of
budget in terms of reach of course we
started with $100 a month budget less
than $1,000 a year actually $80 a month
we start I told my father you're giving
charity so much outside why don't you
give $8 $90 a month so that's how we
started our with one staff that was in
>> mhm
>> and in the span of few years mashallah
we gave having the largest only you know
head office we had 500 paid employees
and more than 10,000
>> 105
>> 500 full-time paid employees
>> 500
>> full-time paid employees and more than
10,000 volunteers only in Bombay
>> 51% to to Allah right so
>> yes no of of income of course other
people who support us
>> so other people so so it's a charitable
organization
>> you were talking about the shadowbans
from social media when were you
shadowbanned by the government because
they always say that you got banned by
the Indian government
>> Indian government I got banned in 2016.
>> So,
>> and the shadowman came after that.
>> So, you were banned from India. You're
not allowed to go to India anymore?
>> No, I can go, but I can't come out.
They'll welcome me. If I go, they'll
they'll welcome me to come in, but they
won't allow me to go out.
>> But what is the reason?
>> The reason basically is because of my
popularity.
>> Is that not because I'm popular only in
Muslims? That's not a problem for
Hindus.
>> I'm popular among the non-Muslims and
the vote bank is trying to bring
division between Hindu and Muslim. and
my talks get unity between Hindu Muslim.
M
>> so after I left the country Modi the
prime minister sent an emissary to me
>> to you know to try and bring
>> Modi right he just said uh Modi did you
see the speech he said India is the
motherland and Israel is the fatherland
>> you saw this like the prime minister
>> so they want me to come back and they
said we will give you everything you
know we'll give all everything we'll
support but of course I'm not there for
money I'm not there for any status they
wanted me to support Kashmir know what
they did in Kashmir I said I cannot do
that you know I cannot don't support
your wrong activities.
>> So they basically want to use your
influence for political gain.
>> Of course. Yes.
>> Because they like
>> if someone uses for a good cause have no
problem but not for the cause which is
haram like they are
>> they are doing such a wrong deed to the
Muslims you know and so so because of
that I did hijra and of course when I
did hijra my activities increased more.
>> So my staff may have reduced but my
activities has increased a lot you know
in terms of politics in terms of meeting
in time to help other people. Previously
it was pure dawa.
>> Now we try and help the Muslim countries
you know try and meet each other.
>> You touched on an idea that I think a
lot of Americans are starting to realize
is that division is intentional to keep
the people divide and conquer. Right.
>> Divide and conquer. Divide and rule.
>> Can you explain that idea? How did you
come to realize that unity is something
that they intentionally don't want us to
have?
>> No. Because if you see the history of
India,
if you know Muslims and they ruled India
for about 800 years,
>> right?
>> India was the most powerful country in
the world at that time.
>> If you see from the 15th 16th century
and in the 16th century when Arang was
the ruler, India had 25% GDP of the full
world more powerful than America in
terms of money.
>> Which year?
>> Uh 16th century.
>> Okay.
>> 15th 17th century 1630. At the time of
Abar and Orang India was the highest. So
25% of the full world GDP
>> was from India
>> from spices right
>> spices or other many things you know
>> gold and jewels and everything
>> and then the British
>> then the Britishers came they came to do
business
>> as a businessman and they cheated
>> and they had their own army
>> and they ruled and they bought a
division between the Muslims. So at the
fault of Muslims also they were divided
and they started you know bribing the
people and that's how the division came
and previously in India Hindu Muslims
were very united even at the time of
Mgals there was no division between
religion so Aarang and Akbar had Hindus
who were the army general and Shivaji
had Muslims who were the army general
you know so it was common there was no
fight there was political fight between
the kings but not because of religion so
when the when the British came
everywhere in the world they divided and
they ruled. So then they took all the
wealth of India sent it to UK and they
started taxing and that's how you know
and the GDP of India completely went
down you know no after they left the
India.
>> Mhm.
>> So in that terms India was a very
powerful country. So then we realize
everywhere uh the the major problem that
the Muslims are facing now is because of
disunityity. Number one and of course
number one is going away from Quran and
Sunnah. If you see history from the 8th
to the 12th century the Europeans called
it the dark ages.
>> Dark ages means we the world was
backward they used to say.
>> Right.
>> But for Islam it was a golden age.
>> Yeah.
>> From the 8th to the 12th century. The
amount of advances that the world made
in science because of Muslims is
phenomenal.
>> Algebra
>> algebra technometry chemistry you name
it. Father of chemistry he's a Muslim.
Right.
Ayan, technome, Alberuni, Aina, you name
it there. So if you had to learn, if you
had to be a scientist, you had to learn
Arabic compulsory and Baghdad was called
the house of wisdom by Hikma. It was the
biggest library in the world.
So all the all the resources of research
was in Baghdad.
>> In Baghdad Iraq,
>> Baghdad India came later. India Muslims
came later on. So that time we had the
kilafhat and we had the Muslims in India
that's the mogul. So both put together
economically India was strong military
the kalafat was strong both put together
we were like untouched like no one could
get then they bought all this sitna and
then they bought division then the
muslims started fighting among
themselves and some of them deviated
from the Quran they started going after
luxury after alcohol so that's how you
found the downfall of the Muslim
caliphate and then the Britishers they
came and they brought a division between
the Muslims in the middle And you know
what's happened all this happen because
of that
>> so can you be our next caliphate
>> sorry no I'm not fit for that
>> for that you are a more qualified person
but of course we can always pray and ask
people to but the Quran says that
inshallah before the end of the world
the caliphate will come back
>> the methi
will come of course inshallah he'll come
and then of course the kilaf also will
come
>> so we're waiting for that for the time
so
>> do you think that this is the start of
the end of times
Yes, but
>> see because there are signs for the end
of the world. There are minor signs and
major signs. Minor signs are many. In my
Facebook post, I mentioned about 87
minor signs and major signs are 10. Some
have said 100, some have clubed
together. So, one of the earliest sign
was the coming of the last and final
messenger.
>> When prophet Muhammad was born and he
became a messenger, that was the
earliest sign for the end of time.
>> But end of time is near. We don't know
whether it's 10 years from now or
thousand years or 10. We don't know. So
no one knows when it will come. But the
signs of the end of world has already
started from the time the prophet
you know because he's the last
messenger.
>> Out of the minor signs majority have
already been fulfilled the right few
pending. So then but how long will it
take? We don't know. Then the 10 major
signs are there. Once that starts coming
the isam will come all these are there.
What are some of the signs that have
occurred recently?
>> There are many.
>> The Burj Khalifa for example is this
one.
>> No, no. The building of B. Prophet said
before the end of time the Muslim will
compete the Arab from the desert will
compete each other with building tall
buildings.
>> Right?
>> So that was BJ Khalif I think was made
in 2014.
>> Yeah.
>> Or something like that.
>> So it's BHJ Khalifa. Then you have
second tallest in in Malaysia.
So the Muslims and then they say that
women we will dress which they're not
very interested transparent all there
are many signs the mid so a sign of the
end of world doesn't mean it's something
which is wrong
>> right
>> most of it may be wrong like coming of
the messenger is a good point so sign of
the end of the world doesn't mean it's a
bad thing
>> right now most of it may be bad majority
>> but coming of the prophet is not bad you
understand now
>> so for example they said the mosque
would be you know would be decorated did
aloat and you find the mosa so there are
uh so most of the minor signs maybe
about 75% are done
>> so as you just spelled out one of the
major faults of the UMA and why we don't
have a a caliphate right now is because
of division
>> divinity
>> what can we do to do our best to bring
more unity right now and this is why you
you've been banned you've been
shadowbanned and banned from governments
because of unity and I I think we now
see
>> how important this is what can we do to
bring unity right now. The reply is in
the hadith of the prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam. Above
prophet said in sunnah Abu Dawud volume
number four had number 4,297.
The prophet said a time will come where
Muslims will be pounced upon. All would
jump on the Muslims as how they jump on
the food.
>> This is happening right now.
>> Ah so then the Sabah asked will the
Muslims be less in number? The prophet
said no Muslim will be in large numbers
but they'll be like fraud. Froth has no
direction. As the wave goes, they keep
on falling. We'll be like froth. And
Allah will take away the fear of the
enemies of Muslims from their heart.
Means enemies of Muslims who would like
who would normally fear Muslims, the
fear would be taken away and Muslim will
have vahan. So the Sahabah asked what is
vahan? The prophet said
the Muslim will love dun and they will
fear death. M
>> so looking at this today the world
population is 8 8.278
billion because I gave a talk yesterday
so whenever I give a talk I update my
statistics whenever I give a new talk as
of yesterday it was 8.278 billion
population out of which more than 25%
are Muslim more than 2 billion or 2.07
07 uh billion are Muslims. Never in the
history of the world have Muslims been
more than 25%. Have they been more than
2 billion? We are in large number. Every
fourth human being is a Muslim. But you
look at the Muslims, we are in a
terrible state. We have been kicked
around. We have been humiliated. We have
been kicked like a football. Why? You
see in the we have minority whether it
be China in the Zingchan area whether it
be the in the the Rohingyas in Myanmar
whether it be Muslims in India whether
in Muslim countries whether it be Yemen
the fighting among themselves in Sudan
in Afghanistan
>> Palestine
>> Palestines attacking what we think we're
doing now Iran
>> Iran
>> I gave that if all
>> a great point two billion but no unity
>> imagine if all and even at the time when
the caliphate was at the weakest
about 100 years ago when the caliphate
was at the weakest weakest at that time
also we were strong because they were
afraid the Muslims are united
>> in the Ottoman war
>> yes even Ottoman time when they were at
the weakest yet they feared the Muslim
because at that time they took out a
drama you know France had taken out a
drama against the prophet so Sultan
Mhammed that time said that you better
stop this drama against the prophet and
they were scared after a few years in
London
They had the same drama again the calif
khif wrote a letter they said this is
not fun this is London he said you don't
know us if I tell what are you going to
do but Muslim um all we'll attack you
and they were afraid that time we were
weak very weak yet they were afraid that
Muslims had the power because there was
one leader today one Muslim country is
fighting against the Muslim country one
Muslim country supporting the second
Muslim country to overpower the third
Muslim country why
>> so we we need a calip then I asked PMS
he said he don't want to you want you
don't want to be the califf. We need
someone who can how do we find some
leadership?
>> No, we can always talk about having a
califf. I mean I don't think so. I have
the qualities of being a calip. I'm a so
of course we require a calip and the
kafhat will come for sure. How long? We
don't know. It is there in the hadith.
So the thing is there that today the
Muslims are more bothered about their
seat in dunya. So I tell in my talks you
don't be bothered about your seat in
Dunya whether you're powerful in a
company or organization or a city or a
state or a country. You strive for your
seat in Jenna
>> and that is eternal seat this seat. So
people are more bothered about they are
taking the help of a non-Muslim country
for protection
>> the GCC like it's yeah you're right
>> and most of the Muslim countries
>> are you banned from the GCC?
>> No no most of them are willing to give
me citizenship. Alhamdulillah. But but
but so I've been offered uh
from 15 countries citizenship but I
prefer you know Malaysia is
>> Malaysia is this a good choice and I I
have to say made
>> taking Malaysia mashallah. So the thing
is that unfortunately of course they
love me they respect me. So we're trying
to use whatever a little bit influence
we have to try to get them closer to
Quran.
>> Right. And now the the situation you see
that we should realize that Allah is the
one if Allah helps you no one can
overcome you. And we see in the history
of the prophet in the battle of Badr
where Muslims only 300 and the
opposition was three times more and they
won the battle.
>> The same thing now you see what's
happening in Afghanistan
>> for more than 20 years they have spent
more than a trillion dollar America and
finally they had to leave Afghanistan.
>> Taliban won against the strongest
military in the world.
>> Well and they were the weakest country.
Now what's happening in Iran?
So with all this top fighter jet F-35
and F16, F-15 and their radar everything
and see so this is so the problem
Muslims should realize that the one who
can protect us best is Allah. So if you
go away from the teachings of Allah.
So when we realize this that Allah is
the one who can and when we start not
fearing death now because we fear death
we are paying billions of dollars to the
kufur non-Muslim to protect us when you
don't fear death. So the prophet said
kahhan will be in the muslim love of dun
and fear of death.
>> So the moment you start not loving dun
that for me wealth is nothing. So if you
start doing that the wealth is nothing
you need a simple life I don't want a
position I don't want to see I want a
nar and then you stop fearing death
that's what happened Taliban they were
not afraid Iran is not afraid so when
they say that you're going to bombard
the bridge or bombard the place where
the nuclear flight is there they are
making human chain imagine other people
run away that is they going to bombard
they run away so they're making a human
chain that means they don't fear death
oh okay we have differences with Iran
correct they have done the atrocities
but that is different at this time. We
should forget our differences.
>> Thank you. You're saying everything that
I want.
>> I'm not we have differences. That's the
different thing. So we're not going to
talk about see at the time of the Sabas.
If you see the history of the prophet
and of the Sahabas, the Sahabas had
differences.
>> But when a third party came to take
advantage, they said you didn't
interfere between we are brothers. We
are Muslim. You know,
>> we will sort it out among ourselves. You
don't come and take advantage. So this
is what we see in the history of the
Sabbath. I have reservation. But now
when the Israel and America are
attacking a Muslim country, how can we
support?
>> Thank you. You're saying exactly what
I've been this whole message of my
content is about especially right now.
So I got a lot of people upset in the
GCC just saying why are you talking
positively about the people of Iran
while clearly they don't fear. So Allah
says that Allah says in the Quran
>> that a one on whom zul is done Muslim is
called on whom operation is done if the
operation's dua even if he's a
non-Muslim
hypothetically I agree they are
non-Muslim you understand now a one on
operation is done Allah listens to the
dua of the oppressed person and if a
non-Muslim country is just
>> yes
>> Allah will support that and if a Muslim
country doing injustice Allah will
support the non-Muslim country which is
on justice rather than a Muslim country
which injustice and said this. So there
are verses in the Quran.
So based on the Quran and hadith there
are differences
that is a different chapter that doesn't
mean I agree with them 100%.
>> Right?
>> At this time there is zoom done on them.
They are being killed whether it be
Gazada whether it be and how can we how
can we just neglect it? That doesn't
mean I'm agreeing with the this time we
have to be united.
>> Thank you. Yes,
>> we have to be united. And and you see
that's what the Quran says. That's what
the prophet did. That's what the Sabas
did. That's what the farid did.
>> The problem is we afraid of death.
>> That's it. And see what's happening now
with all the latest technology, latest
radar system, billions of dollar.
They're spending more than a million
dollar a day to survive. And they using
cheap drones of 20,000
>> 50k drones, 5k drones,
>> 20,000 drone. when they attacking a
billion dollar
>> right destroying
>> so so and this is the thing that we
should not love this world we should be
more bothered that our final destination
is a so if you lead the life that where
will I benefit more he's a better
businessman so these people are
short-term businessmen they only bother
about this world so if you look at the
see we are going to live in this world
for how long 70 years 80 years 90 years
not more than that maximum 100
>> compared to the a which is eternal so if
you're a good businessman that if I give
you some difficulty, if I give you some
pain for the small 0001 person compared
to Dhaka, you would love okay I don't
mind having pain if you're doing an
operation you're giving an injection
you're getting a poke but then you're
going to be cured so comparatively even
if you see in this world you have
difficulties you have turmoil you have
to face something it's good it's a test
>> for the examination you study hard you
sleep less for that few hours so that
you get a good result
>> exactly
>> so Allah says in surah mul chapter 6
Number two,
Allah has created death and life to test
which of his good indeed. See all of
these people Muslim countries I don't
take name normally when I talk you know
many I meet I know them we have to guide
them
>> it is not see and we have to guide with
hikma
>> see talking see if I'm going to talk
something and they won't accept what
they use okay I've done my duty but you
have do with hikma you should not I
always tell that if you want to talk to
someone who's on high power whether it
be the government whether it be a big
celebrity do with hikma you can't insult
them if you insult them the chances
you'll win them more less
They have to speak with hikma with love
because our main duty is to win them
over not difficult
>> not to prove them wrong. What are you
going to do? We do our job in the best
of ability as Allah says in chapter 16
verse 125
invite all to the way of the lord with
wisdom and beautiful preaching. So if
you do it this wisdom not that okay see
I spoke the truth
>> I I gave good to that country. I gave
good to that president.
>> What is the benefit? Are you trying to
score points here?
>> Yeah.
>> We are trying to win. Follow the Quran.
>> So
>> you want to win them over, not defeat.
>> Win them over. Correct. So same way in
the Quran. See, when I'm giving advice
to a normal person is different when I'm
giving advice to the head of states is
different. This is what Islam says. I
cannot just bombard even if I'm right
you know I will push them over in fact
more on the other side. You have to win
them over you know. So so if Allah has
given you Allah has made you a celebrity
for example. So it's your duty not just
to okay I'm a celebrity I've come on the
social media spoken the truth class no
okay that's there speaking truth is
better than not speaking truth but that
is only small portion you have done
>> your job is to win them so when you're
giving advice your advice should even
touch their heart
>> you so that as there are some people
some very few who take names and they
criticize and they keep on bombarding I
gave the message with hikma I told many
things now so without taking names so
those who are intelligent is who I'm
speak who I'm speaking about because our
job is that if they like you as a
celebrity, how do you influence them to
come on duck is is your job.
>> You have to speak with love. I can see
why you're a threat now. I I understand
you probably don't get into debates the
way that we're used to now. A lot of the
conversation a screaming matches
>> depending where you are. If if you're in
a boxing match, you have to give a
knockout. If I'm on a debate on the
stage, I'm like different. They have to
be like a line. Correct? But not sure.
So main job is to get the people close
to Quran and
>> right
>> whether it be a non-Muslim, whether it
be anyone, whether it be a Muslim not
practicing Islam. So that's what after I
did my hijra besides my dava on the
stage, we're involved in know speaking
with different heads.
>> We're not there to humiliate them. We're
here to invite them.
>> It doesn't make see
>> it's important to remember
>> it doesn't make any it will not benefit
you. There are already 100 people
thousand people speaking against them.
>> Yeah.
>> What is it?
>> Huh? One thing is there you cannot
support them for sure
>> right
>> instead of supporting speaking against
them is better but the best is invite
them
because if they call you to to meet you
and you're meeting them and you have an
opportunity because you're a celebrity
so you have to take advantage of and
depending upon how close you are because
I'm in many heads of states Muslim
country you know many so then depending
how big a fan he is of yours you give
that advice and Allah has blessed us
that we okay some people listen to
advice Some people don't, some people.
So, we have to do our job of just
delivering the message whether he agrees
or not. That's that's it. So,
>> so I'm I'm sure you get this all the
time. When you speak about Iran, they're
going to say this or they're going to
say you're Shia, you're Sunni, you're
Hanafi, you're Sufi, you're Salafi.
>> What are you?
>> I'm a Muslim. Alhamdulillah.
>> Allah says in the Quran in many places,
call and Muslims, you're a Muslim.
There's no in the Quran call yourself
Hanfi Shafi Hali Maliki or a Shia or
Sunni. I respect all the all the four.
Immifa, I shi imal
may Allah bless them all. They were
great scholars. They never gave fatwas
to bring divisions. They came to explain
the dean.
So if there's a difference in analysis
of fake it's more than 90% are same in
the 10% what they differ this you may be
5% more correct 7% so all of them are 92
to 98% correct
and the difference is not minor issues
not a major issue
>> right
>> whether it is which is preferable where
you keep your hand down or top okay I'll
do research
>> I will follow but I'll not give a talk
where to keep the hand I will give a
talk of pray
>> right
>> you should pray I'll not give a talk
where to keep your understand whether
you do or not.
>> Mhm.
>> I'm very particular. I am very strict in
following. I will wear the toes above
the ankle. Correct. But if someone
differs wearing is is not a major sin, I
will not fight over that. I'm very
strict in my research. And I follow
Aruni to convince me difficult. Correct?
But if the difference no scholar said,
no imam said if you don't keep your hand
on top your salah won't be accepted or
you don't do rafat. So these are binary
issues. I want plus points. I'll do
research but I don't give a talk on I
give a talk or you should pray.
So you should try and win. So that is
the reason the reason that the audience
is large I I don't believe in getting
disunityity like in India there are many
sects in Islam and there were some
people some scholars D used to speak
against people literally abuse meh so
when we have the conference we have the
largest conference in the world and one
of the conference I called a person
who's against me who literally abuses
been public. I call him to give lecture
on my stage. people are shocked. I said,
"How come?" I said, "See, there is no
verse in the Quran or hadith which says
if you speak against Dr. Zak, you will
not go to Jenna." I don't know. Correct.
He's speaking on Allah and his rasool.
I'll call him. He's speaking against me.
No problem. Because there's no verse in
the Quran that say if you speak again,
you will not go to Jenna. I call him and
once he comes on my stage on my also he
speaks against me. Then he becomes my
friend. Disunityity gone.
>> Mhm. And if someone abuses me does it
make a difference to me?
>> In fact, it's better. I get plus points.
>> If someone abuses me falsely, I get his
good deeds. Correct? So if you we people
should not be what will happen to my
image today. You know what will happen
if he's abusing me? So we should rather
get unity. So in this way when we
started in India we had the largest
conference. So we call when we call
people we call hanafi shafi humbly mali
salafi know of course we have our
limitations we don't we won't call those
who completely we feel are gone out you
know but these small differences and not
that I have to agree with it so when you
what am I said callusim
the verse I quoted to you which says you
should be a in the ending what it says
say that I'm a Muslim so the best person
is the one who calls people to Allah
does righteous deed and same a Muslim.
So there are empty number of places
Allah says call yourself a Muslim
Muslim. So if someone calls himself a
shafi no problem because he's saying
that I'm not a scholar I'm just
following the teachings of one imam no
problem there's no issue
>> right but what did prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam what did he
>> that's for me see he he pro he followed
Quran and sunnah
>> exactly
>> later on these are great scholars
>> because after the prophet passed away
there were difference in interpreting
the hadith
>> understanding the Quran and the
differences are minors these four great
ayas or if you follow any one of them
inshallah you'll go to Jenna correct now
the differences is not all say pray five
times all say give charity all say zakat
the difference may be you know okay if
you do this you'll get.1% extra correct
>> how everyone says pray whether you keep
your hand on top or down do research but
that's
>> because I want to score very high first
you pass the exam if you're not praying
you'll fail
>> you know so so if you want to enter into
medical college in India you require
more than 95% % you know so to get 80
marks is very easy after that 80 to 90
is difficult after 90 every 1% is
difficult after 90 every.1% is difficult
you understand so first you pass the
exam
>> so because we want a very high so we'll
be very particular in the research
>> but these are small differences right
>> so once you start getting people
together of different schools of thought
and the Muslims and different races then
you'll find the unity
>> and then we wouldn't be kicked around
like a football
>> now we are being kicked If we unite then
we won't be
>> we could be the kicker the kickers.
>> Yes. Not we won't kick. We'll win them.
We'll be the protectors
>> the coach or the referee.
>> We don't like kicking. We like okay
>> you come play with us and
>> that's when the unity is.
>> Yeah. That the reason we we always we
always pray that you know if you see the
prophet when the two um were there who
against Islam so so prophet prayed to
Allah let one Omar accept Islam and Omar
Kab accept it.
>> Mhm. So that's how I used to say that
you know that when I used to give
lectures and George Bush and Tony Bless
may Allah give that to one
I gave a talk in in UK in the early 2000
talk on unity and one of these people
who I know the militant Muslims I in the
group they get up and say mashallah very
good lecture death to George Bush death
to Tony full full talk of my god so I
giving a talk on winning the non-Muslims
now this person saying mashallah Dr.
like very good that to
>> then I said no no no this is not I say
give them correct
>> so I also say that may Allah give to
Trump or give to Nitanyu
>> you know so then nothing better
>> what is the difference between giving
dawa to Hindus which you seem to be an
expert in and Christians
>> see I think the strategies of the Quran
is the same but people know more of the
Bible so to give dawa to a Christian
becomes easier Here people don't know
much about the scriptures of the Hindus
because there are many dies who have
worked including Shik Ahmed Dad have
given talks on Islam and Christianity.
Very few D are giving talks on Islam and
Hinduism. The first time when I gave a
talk similarities in Islam and Hinduism
they were fatwa against me. Dr. Zaki is
saying the similarities between Islam
and Hinduism impossible. In Dubai
they took out a protest against me. I
said at least listen to my talk. after I
give the talk if I've said one thing
wrong in this Quran so I can catch my
color.
>> Mhm.
>> And I give a talk talk proving that even
they talk about and giving all reference
in Sanskrit. So there they aren't many
talks on Islam and Hinduism.
>> Well you said that they talk about and
Hinduism
>> of course no they don't
>> no almost not Hindu almost all the
religions all the religion whether Hindu
Judaism Christianity Hinduism parismism
all of them talk about and that's what
the Quran says
>> really good. So, so after the scriptures
got corrupted, all scriptures except the
Quran got corrupted. But there are two
major points I then all scriptures about
and about Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam. So all the script the all the
religions if you read the scriptures
somewhere or the other it's mentioned
about and even mentioned about the
coming of prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam.
>> Mhm.
>> What does it say in Hinduism about the
coming of Prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam?
>> About the prophecy of Muhammad multiple
times more than the Bible. more than the
Bible and the Bible is mentioned by name
once you said right the Bible is
mentioned by name once in in Hindu
scriptures more than 100 times is
mentioned by name 100 times
>> by name by name prophecies are more than
that few hundred so I've given a talk on
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
mentioned in in the Hindu scriptures in
one of the one of the khali purana
chapter 2 verse number 5 7 11 14 15 17
it even says that his mother's name
would be Amina.
Father's name would be Abdullah. It says
Vishnu Yas. If you translate that will
be Abdullah.
>> He'll be born in city of peace that is
Makkah. He'll be born in the family of
the chief of the city of Makkah. He'll
have four close companions.
>> He will fight against the devil. He'll
have angels.
>> You don't find in the Bible all this.
>> No.
>> So, but the problem is people did not do
much research on the Hindu scriptures.
So, Shik Da told me that son, I have
done a lot of Christianity. Why don't
you study Hinduism? So that's what you
know he inspired me to study on Hindu
scriptures and we did part three
scriptures and the other scriptures and
that's how now we're giving talks on
comparative religion.
>> What is the mention of the prophet in
the Bible that says that there will be
one that will come 400 years later
Ahmed.
>> Yes. Yes. Many places see by name is
mentioned in the
Solomon chapter 5 verse 16.
The word there's mhammed in the in
seemitic languages you add him for
respect like elo for Allah Elohim for
respect so for Muhammad they added
Muhammad but in the translation they
write he's altogether lovely so he
mentioned my name otherwise references
if the is mentioned in the old testament
and new testament the most powerful is
the book of deuteronomy chapter chapter
number 18 verse number 18 I can quote
that will take two hours
>> yeah
chapter number 18 verse number
Then the book of Isaiah chapter number
12 verse number 29 then in the New
Testament Gospel of John 14:6 John 15:26
John chapter number 16 verse number 7
John 16 verse number 11 to 14 the last
one I have many things to say unto you
Jesus Christ peace be upon me say I have
many things to say unto you but he
cannot bear them now for he when the
spirit of truth shall come he shall
guide you into all truth he shall not
speak of himself all that he shall he
speak so each reference you can speak
for 10 minutes 20 minutes half an So
I've given a separate talk on Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam in the Bible
and there I mentioned many prophecies
from the Old Testament from the New
Testament.
>> I know you have uh some questions as
well. I wanted
>> Yeah. Well, I mean talking about Hindu
scriptures uh we had an experience
yesterday where you want to ask them
about that but you know where we
>> so basically I'm just wondering what the
major difference is about how to give
dawa to them. So you you said that the
Hindus for example they don't know the
scriptures as well. Christians, they'll
know their Bible better. But is there
really that much of a difference in
speaking to them? Because Hindus, they
believe in that there's three billion
gods. Yes. Three three billion gods and
there
>> 33 crores.
>> Three what?
>> 33 330 million.
>> That's what I heard. But he said three
billion. So he got it wrong. He doesn't
even know how many gods he believes in.
>> See, see when you quote Nafi when I tell
I'll give you reference. Some people
just say anything and exaggerate. So
when you I tell the people be exact. For
example, there is one of the gods
Krishna. I don't say thousands of god
yet 16,18.
So when I say 16,18 exact number and I
give the reference where it is mentioned
they this person authentic. So people
sometime exaggerate. Now why you want to
exaggerate when the scripture says 330
million why you have to say billion. So
some of the people they don't remember
>> they don't remember how many gods they
believe in.
>> No no no some of the dies when they
criticize or when they you should be
exact.
>> He wasn't he wasn't a d he was a Hindu.
Oh, Hindu. No, no, Hindus. No, see that
is they may believe unlimited. That's
different. But the scripture mentions
three 30 million. You understand?
>> The scripture.
>> But so there's three main like a trinity
for that. Krishna, Vishnu and another
one
>> and Sha
>> and the main one he was saying was the
god of destruction.
>> Sha overall is there a major difference
in the communication or do you find it
easier?
>> See the strategy is the same.
>> The strategy is the same.
>> The methodology is same but the
information is different. For example,
the master key for dawa is Imran 3:64
come to common terms as been assigned.
The starting of the versita meaning Jud
and the Christian come to common terms
has been asended.
So always when you talk come to common
term don't talk about differences. If I
attack the Bible if I attack the Qur
attack the Hindu scripture what benefit
is for me?
>> So talk about the similarity. Mhm.
>> So if I can give a talk of 2 hours on
similarities, I can give a talk of four
hours on different.
>> So how do you talk about the
similarities?
>> Correct. That's then you do research.
>> Correct. So and among the similarities,
Allah says which is the most important
Allah that you worship none but Allah.
So while talking about similarities
because interested in science, you can
start with science but your main focus
should be. So I tell a you can start
with if he likes sports, you start with
sports. If he likes literature, starts
with literature. But your main focus
should be you may convince him to be a
good person be charitable you may
convince him that not to have poke not
to have alcohol but if I don't take away
the shik from his life that is useless
>> if that non-Muslim is a Hindu or
Christian leave pork leave alcohol will
he go to Jenna no so I can talk other
things but my main focus should be Allah
worship none but Allah
>> and then talking about so when I start
dawa I will not directly jump to God I
may talk to about what he likes oh he
likes science or Quran speaks about big
man speaks about that. So for a
Christian it's easy because we know many
speakers talking about the Bible and
Bible in volume maybe approximately
three times more than the Quran in terms
of volume
>> like that
>> Hindu scriptures are hundreds of times
volumeist so it's difficult to read
everything Bible to read is easy so so
what I tell so when we have Dava
training program we don't tell them to
read the full Bible
we tell we we make them memorize certain
verses of these 15 are the most
important then 15 then this 150 verses
you memorize you can debate with the
pope also. So what we do we do a
research what the Christian missionaries
use to convince the Muslims
>> Mhm.
>> to accept Christianity we take them out
and memorize them.
>> What verses they use to prove Jesus is
God we memorize them.
>> Then what verses are required to do the
hardly 150 200. Once you master them
they will come and tell you you know
Jesus Christ said I and my father are
one. Oh your quoting gospel of John
chapter 10 vers 30 he's shocked he knows
the verse he doesn't know the reference
so when the Christian missionary comes
and says that Jesus Christ peace be upon
him said I my father a one oh so you're
quoting gospel of John chapter 10 vers
30 he's shocked he's not trained to give
references so when he's quoting his
bible as a Muslim wearing a cap and a
beard I quote his Bible half the battle
is won he's shocked
>> he's saying what is this person I'm
quoting the Bible he's giving the
reference then I give the context you're
quoting out of context where is the
context context text starts from gospel
of John chapter 10 verse number 22 when
Jesus Christ peace be upon him enters
the temple of Solomon. So he's shocked.
He only knows that one verse. I'm
telling him few verses afterwards and
few verses later.
>> Wait, what is the context of that
statement? I I and the father won. Oh,
>> you want the context? Okay, everything.
Yeah. Yeah,
>> it's true. I can it'll take time. I have
time. So the thing is that see they say
I and my father trying to prove that
Jesus Christ came divinity. So if you
read the context from verse number 22
gospel of John chapter 10 it says that
Jesus Christ entered the temple of
temple of Solomon on the poor and the
Jews surrounded him and they asked him
that if thy if thou art the Christ tell
us plainly. So Jou Christ let us know.
>> If thou thou art the Christ tell us
plainly tell us plainly plain if thou
art the God. So he said I told you but
you know me not for those who follow me
they know me they follow me and they
obey me and the work that I do speaks
about my father so now he's giving the
context Jesus Christ peace be upon him
he's giving he's giving the context that
you don't know me but my followers know
me those who know me they believe me
they follow me and they obey me huh then
verse number 27
My father is greater than all. My father
who gave it to me is greater than all.
They saying that father talk about
almighty god. So saying we're one is
like one message. I
>> I'll come to it once I come to verse 30.
We'll come to so he says that the father
who gives it to me is greater than all.
And then he says I and my father are
one. That means he's telling father
talking about god I and my god are one
in purpose. He said that no man can plug
them out of my hand. Verse number 27,
Jesus Christ says, "No man can plug them
out of my hand. My father who give it to
me is greater than all. No man can plug
them out of my father's hand." He's
talking about the disciples. I and my
father Aan. He's talking about in
purpose in delivering the message,
>> okay,
>> of God. You understand now?
>> Right?
>> So if I say I and my father are one, my
father is a medical doctor. I'm a
medical doctor. So if I say I and my
father one doesn't mean that we are one
one human being
>> but one purpose
>> they have one as medical doctors correct
>> so here okay it doesn't end there then
verse number 31 says the Jews pick up
stone to stone him when he says I and my
father are one so he says for which of
the works do you stone me so the Jews
reply you claim to be God
>> the Jews are telling they also
misunderstood that Jesus is claiming
divinity verse number 33 Three says it
is mentioned in the scripture the person
to whom the word has come is called as
god.
>> We are gods. So he's telling that a
person who the word has come god means
small god. So he's a person of god. So
he's trying to say that in purpose we
are same not as one entity. And then
furthermore if you see in gospel of John
chapter 17 Jesus Christ peace be upon
him says to his disciples to 12 is you
and me we are one same one is used here.
So does it mean that there are 13 gods
>> based off that the disciples would also
be god. Yes. So we have to give context.
>> Yeah.
>> So we have question answer session which
we encourage. Normally in religious
lectures when a person gives a lecture
he doesn't enter in question answer
session because that is the best part to
know how much knowledgeable the speaker
is to give a talk is easy you can
memorize any talk any book and vomit it
out correct
>> the best is question answer session and
in the question answer when you give
quotation the battle is won
>> what's interesting is basically the
Christians who are using that to claim
Jesus is divine they're making the same
mistake that the Jews made when they
thought that
>> correct
>> the ones the Jews that stoned or tried
to stone Jesus there are the making the
same mistakes the Christians are making
today.
>> Correct.
>> Wow.
>> And what about they say uh Jesus says I
am the way, the truth and the
>> correct. This is from Gospel of John
chapter 14 verse number six.
>> Okay.
>> See you quoted. I'm giving the
reference.
>> Yeah.
>> So this is the training.
>> Sorry one more time. I I'll study later.
I don't want to repeat.
>> I said you said you told me the J said
the truth in my life. So I said this
reference is of gospel of John chapter
number 14 verse number six.
>> 14 verse number six. I'm giving the
reference of what you quoted.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Gospel of John chapter 14
verse number six. Correct. For context
go to verse number one.
>> Yeah.
>> And I am the way, the truth and the life
you tell me. Correct.
>> So verse number one says that in my
father's house are in my father's house
are many mentions. You see I'm going
there I'm going there to prepare a place
for you. Jesus is telling the disciples
now. Okay. If you love God, if you love
me also, that if you have trust in God,
trust me also. I'm going to prepare a
place for you. So Thomas asked and he
says, "You know where I go." Thomas
says, "We don't know where you go."
>> Thomas is saying to Jesus, "You we don't
know where you're going." Then he says,
"I am the way, the truth, and the life.
No man cometh unto the father but
through me." Mhm.
>> Now in all religions, even in Islam, the
messenger at that time was the truth,
the way and the life. No man came to God
but through the messenger. So at the
time of Moses, Moses peace be upon him
was the way, the truth, and the life. No
man came to God but through Moses. At
the time of Jesus, so we agree with that
100%. At the time of Jesus Christ peace
be upon him, Jesus was the way, the
truth, and the life. No man came to God
but through Jesus peace be upon him. at
the time of Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam. Mhamad Salah. So it is we
agree with it. It's not wrong.
So he's the way and the truth. That
doesn't make him go. That makes him a
person of God. Makes him a messenger of
God.
>> Mhm.
>> That's uh unbeatable. And it gets I
think what the important thing you keep
reiterating is that when you memorize a
script, you study their gameplay.
>> Yes. the game plan the same way Mike
Tyson is watching his opponent before he
gets in there.
So
>> and so you know what's going to come
there.
>> So in our training what we do all these
famous missionaries what they quote we
memorize. So when they come we are
prepared.
>> Mhm.
>> Not that I'm half of the Bible. I don't
know the Bible by heart but I know what
they're going to speak. So people think
I'm half of the Bible. I'm not half the
Bible.
>> Mhm.
>> I don't know full Bible by heart. But I
know those verses which are important
for the
>> Does anybody know the Bible by heart?
>> I don't think so. I don't think there's
one Bible husband.
>> Right. Do you ever find it difficult as
a personal question with dealing with
the disbelievers and the coffer and the
enemies of Islam?
Does your dean get corrupted
communicating with these people? Because
right now this is a a form of hra in a
way going to Malaysia and this and I'm
way more at peace around the Muslims but
I'm from New York and there's physical
attacks there's mental attacks there's
people constant there's evil eye and you
get pulled away from the dean and it's
it's it's your fault but the difference
between you know Ramadan when you're in
Medina and Mecca around the believers
and then back home in the land of the
disbelievers it's very it's the polar
opposites and you having dealt with all
these quote, "How do you protect your
iman from the people that want to
destroy it?"
>> See, that's very important.
>> Uh, number one, you should realize that
for a D, see, for a normal Muslim
praying, praying five times is fur. But
for the prophet, six time was fur. Even
the tajul
prayer,
>> the late night prayer,
>> he didn't sleep much. He slept three
hours at night and then woke up for that
prayer.
>> The exact is not mentioned, but he used
to sleep less. I know because you sleep
less. The the Quran says he used to
stand up and pray oneird of the night,
sometime half the night, sometime twoird
of the night.
>> Mhm.
>> That's what the Quran says. So now what
you have to understand that for a d I
tell him that even praying taj is
important that the time in taj you pray
in the last one third of night as much
as you can with half an hour one or two
hours four hours five as much as you can
>> you pray to every night.
>> Yes.
For me you sir
>> it's not a fur but it for me I made it a
on me and and the more we pray better
you know 1 hour two or three so
depending upon you know so and in all
the activities in the day the maximum
spend time is on salah on average about
5 and a half hours in a day if I count
all the five salas 5 and a half hours
every day for you
>> totally in a day counting the salah I go
for the salah every salah about half an
hour then
>> five and a half every day I thought
salah was supposed to be uh 30 minutes
about in total is well you do owe that
extra prayers
>> no no no no extra prayers you can finish
in 30 minutes easily but if you do extra
prayers total 50 four I can give the
breakdown and plus I confirm that I'm at
a voodoo I go down and come up so each
salah may take 30 minutes and then the
taj of course average 2 hours sometimes
3 hours sometime four hours sometimes 5
hours in the night so the more you do
it's better it is so now to protect
yourself you should be realize that
especially people like you who are
celebrities number one sometimes the
fame comes to your head,
the fame gets the better of you, the
fame.
So for celebrities, we should always uh
remind them that the Satan is trying to
target those who are more successful in
the de. So I pray to Allah every night
that please save me from the sh from the
Satan from the shaitan from tempting.
>> So do that's my number one.
>> So that we remember our our great
suhammed may Allah be pleased with him.
We had large audience thousand at that
time thousand is great. So once when
large audience come and he says wow what
a large audience the moment the thought
came he closed his book and didn't give
the talk
you know so that to kill his to kill his
ego and happens with that when you see
you know like I remember when I was
young one of my imag last gather be
12,000 people in Birmingham so my aim
was to get 12,000 people I'm talking
about myself when I was young oh I want
to get at least a gold medal in sports
you know then Allah made me a long
distance 10 km I got a gold medal Then I
say shita okay shita largest audience is
birmingham and 12,000 that's my target
but that's nothing so that becomes the
immediate target but then when we get
more experience these are these are not
a milestone the milestone is to please
Allah so coming back to it when you're
doing dawa there may be times when
people may put difficult questions to
you and there are time that you may feel
like oh what's happened you know it may
even question your iman
so number One, you should always have
people around you also in consultation
with you that if such questions are put
you should know someone who's close to
you who can reply or sometimes it's very
dangerous
>> while doing that especially now in the
age of atheism you know the debate is
going on and they may attack certain
questions and of course there are
certain questions which when I pose like
when I came across I pose many other
Muslims we put too of course we don't
tell that in public we only talk to
scholars about that you know So you
while doing dawa you should have someone
who you should be in the company or you
know who's knowledgeable who can help
you in the situation or it can take you
out
of the fold of Islam you understand now
because you're in the limelight and
everyone is there trying to attack you
and they may say something which may
sound very lo and I've got so my main
specialtity is now that when I have the
weekly question session I have a
question session ask Dr. Zak uh twice a
uh a month. So first and third Friday I
handle uh second and fourth my son
handle our doctor. So we get about
20,000 questions in a week. Out of that
my staff doesn't read all they may read
four 5,000 they give me 100 questions
from that I answer about 20. So I pick
up those questions which are mainly not
on not on fake how to pray and all that
everyone is doing on those questions
which attack Islam logically. For
example,
Allah is in my game. Okay, he has
knowledge. If Allah has all the
knowledge, then why are you why are you
asking dua? Allah knows a logical
question. Correct? If Allah knows what's
in your heart, why should you ask? Allah
should give you without asking. Very
logic. So these are questions which
answers are not there in the book of
fake. It's not the religious book. It's
about mental. It's it's about logic. So
I am more involved in picking up those
questions which are attacking the de
logically.
scientifically. So that's my
specialtity. One is comparative religion
is we did that because these questions
may not come in general public. So when
we get 20,000 questions, we select those
which are difficult questions. So how to
reply to them is a different art.
>> So when you're doing dawa, there may be
times when someone may take out
something some mistakes in the Quran
which which maybe the ground will be
taken away from your feet. It has
happened for me. If someone ask a
question against Islam, I don't go to
sleep until I get the answer. That's my
that's my nature. So I remember in the
early days of my dawa so out of the
question till I don't get the answer I
will not sleep. Of course now getting
experience meeting so many people. So
all these questions have become in
thousands and so Allah helps us. So
therefore if you're doing dawa and so
you should always be in touch with good
company. Fine you may have your other
friends
>> but especially for dava you should be in
the company of knowledgeable people you
should have contact you should have
their phone number it should not be that
suddenly you get you know off guard and
then it has happened many times many of
the good but they are caught on the
wrong
foot and it becomes a disaster
>> so keep people of knowledge around you
>> always always keep people better than
you and who are more Islamic in your
Mhm.
>> As the prophet said hadith that if you
are in the company of a coal smith then
you'll get the core on your shirt on
your hand. If you're in the company of a
perfume person who's selling perfume
like
>> I know you had a lot more.
>> So uh I want to ask you what do you
believe the da scene is missing today
from your experience?
>> It's not missing. I cannot say it's
missing. It is there but of course it
should be better. Dawas are missing
>> look what what can be better from the
dawa that you see today. Oh
>> what can be better? See now because of
science and technology
the the core
core of method is the same but the
medium may change see number one another
pro the direct dhava that's it direct
dhava can be of three types broadly one
is one to one is giving in a group one
is giving a lecture in public like that
of the prophet the one to one is the
most effective I'll just give an example
if I speak suppose a person is a very
expert
and he speaks two hours with a
non-Muslim 10 different non-Muslims. If
he's a very expert good D maybe he'll
convince one it's not possible to
convince 10. This is all nonsense. Some
people say okay I can convert a person
in 10 is all nonsense. But if he's a
very good D if he speaks two hours with
10 different individuals 20 hours if
he's very good maybe he'll convince one
correct. So the effectiveness is 10%. If
he's giving a talk in a group of 100
people correct maybe he'll convince two
people in that one talk of so the
effective is 2%. But here in
20 in in 10 hours he's conver convincing
1% here if you give 10 lectures he's
converting 20 people but effectiveness
is 2% out of 100 to accepting Islam.
Here the effectiveness 10%. So one to
one dhava the effectiveness is more but
the reach is less
you understand effectiveness is 10%.
>> Mhm.
>> 10%. Why?
Then if you're giving a group
effectiveness is 2%.
>> But the time required is less.
>> Mhm.
>> So in their 20 hours I'm convincing one
person effectiveness is 10%. In group
effectiveness is 2% but in 10 hours I'm
convincing 20 people. Mhm.
>> Correct? If I'm giving a public lecture
thousand people maybe if I will accept
Islam
>> effectiveness is.5%.
>> Maybe not immediately but the ideas and
the knowledge stays with them.
>> No I'm saying hypothetically yes that's
different. One is he hears my lect some
that that different I'm not talking
about generally just hypothetical
situation
>> right
>> that a person doesn't know about Islam
to convince him two hours are difficult
but someone is an expert
>> right
>> so I'm effectiveness one to1 is more but
as as the audience keeps on increasing
reach increases effectiveness decreases
but I would prefer giving lecture in
public I convince more so you keep the
one to one for celebrities
because one president or a king or a
prime minister is equal to thousand
people so I wouldn't want to convince is
a person like I'll call the king in a
public come in a public lecture and
you'll hear my lecture. The
effectiveness is 5% there. I prefer
calling one to one because if I convince
him as as I'm convincing thousand you
understand now. So the prophet also
spoke to the head of the one to one. You
understand now? So now when you go to
media when you go to media on the on the
on the Facebook you having more people
100,000 1 million 10 million on the
satellite 100 million there
effectiveness is 01% but the reach is
200 million or 100 million or 1 million
you understand? So effectiveness goes
down but the reach increases net result
is better on the media.
>> So therefore previously I used to meet
everyone individually when I was
starting but as the demand keeps on
increasing I meet onetoone less
>> but I would love to meet but I cannot if
I start meeting everyone onetoone to
meet me even if I have in a day a
thousand hours I cannot meet everyone
correct. So then we called them to puta
mosque. There in just 5 minutes I meet
about people after the mosque people
come because I cannot refuse. You
understand? Then some people come to
this mosque after I meet for 2 minutes.
Some people like we call them spending
hours also. You understand? So
effectiveness is more onetoone but the
but the reach becomes less. So same
thing in media now coming back to your
question media we have to utilize media.
But I cannot say I will target my media
with the press. Oh on the way in the
group if he hears that accept
alhamdulillah but if someone is going to
give me a time I can speak to this
president or this prime minister one to
one or would you prefer I'll call him
for the lecture if he's giving two hours
I will say one to one is better why
lecture you understand one to1 the
effectiveness is 10%.
In the group 2% in a lecture.1%.
on the on the social media points but
the reach is so much. So now
we have three types of training. One is
we have a school where we train for 15
years how to become a dai right from
nurseries and age three to A levels.
Then then we have other training
programs which is for 45 days and the
best is peace TV.
Millions are watching but the
effectiveness dies. I get so many I just
two days back someone gave me send me a
video of the sunnah guy I never heard of
him so he got inspired by my talk so
there are every time every day how many
accepting Islam we don't know tens
hundreds every day in a talk I can't do
that one to one I cannot so because of
my satellite and the med every day
hundreds are accepting Islam
>> every day alhamdulillah and how many
Muslims are becoming d hundreds
>> even if without any program how can I
train them you understand and the
material is there if he wants to search
it have to waste me waste my time. He
searches okay this lecture that lecture
there are a few hundred lectures of fine
so how to d them so all are important
book is important video is important
internet is important social media is
important each one has its own pros and
cons I cannot say now I become popular
say I will not meet anyone onetoone no
one to one is also important so
depending upon who you're meeting
what is the effectiveness I would prefer
onetoone then ask him to watch my videos
>> and do you watch dawa content right now
like Are you currently
>> for the speakers? Few
>> do you mind sharing?
>> See all the top all the top dies I know
personally around any top anyone that
reaches more than 1 minute is is on our
scanner
>> and most of them have come all almost
all of the D all the top has come here
and they meet you understand and then of
course we have our own system. So
previously of course like we had the
largest conference in the world. I can
show you a documentary of that. That is
the largest conference if you see
martial 250,000 people and the stage is
massive 13,000 ft² stage like it
competes with the Hollywood you know. So
it was my desire to have a program
utilizing the technology of the
Hollywood for halal activity. It was my
desire to have the conference once
>> but then we had it every year.
>> Then the band came and we had to lift.
So we had for 5 years.
>> Do you do you miss being out there in
the front lines? Of course, see Bombay
was different. See, India was
battlefield. I missed that because you
can't get that much audience, that much
technology, that many people. You can
get in some countries like Bangladesh
and Indonesia. But India was wonderful
and the question that we received from
there and 25% of my audience were
non-Muslims over there. 25%. So the so
the questions we got it gave us more
food for thought you know. So more
people attack alike.
So that makes us come more closer to
Islam and help them also come mash.
>> How effective is the shahada? Sometimes
you can give dawa to somebody and
convince them
>> and then they they say shahada and then
I see them again a year later.
>> I say, "Oh, hey, I remember you." And he
says, "Oh yeah, I remember I took
shahada with you." I'm like, "How are
you?" He's like, "Well, you know,
I'm not practicing or anything." So yes,
he did take shahada in the moment and
they believe but if they're not around
the right situations and surroundings
then they're not actually any better a
lot of the times
>> for giving shada there are mainly two
broad categories one is who you have met
many times maybe he's coming to your
organization 10 20 times he's asked he
he maybe had 10 talks with me 10 talks
with other guys and you know this person
is convinced over a period of few months
now when I'm giving a talk someone comes
on the on the mic and says I want to
give shada I've seen your lecture for
the past 2 years so I'm not going to
question him I accept it but when he
says he's been seeing my lectures for
the past 2 years that means it's not a
one time sometimes you meet people on
the spot and then tell him to take shada
the chances he remain is very less so I
don't I'm not in favor of meeting a
person the first time unless he has seen
my videos for the past maybe several
months or several years but I'm p I'm
meeting a person for the first time and
here's about and I explain to him Islam
and and I may convince him to read the
shada but the chances he'll be as a part
of Muslim is very less I'm not in favor
of asking anyone just in the meeting to
shada unless I know that he he has been
listening to other speakers or you know
so there are people who just go out on
the street and uh but I'm not against it
also I'm not against it also why because
they never know
many people who take for him sake shada
or because they love a Muslim girl and
they take shada
But yet afterwards they may pick up
practicing.
>> So it's not wrong but I don't normally
encourage myself directly but if someone
who takes a shada and maybe he meets
what happens later on he may meet
someone and then he may start to
practice Islam. So depending on how you
give shad is very important but
generally just going on in the market
and talking and asking the shada is not
that it's not effective in the long run.
It's not wrong but the chances that
he'll stay. So therefore there are many
people shada online and I've done a
survey on this
>> there are dies who speak online dawa
they talk they call how many shadas I
give in the fully ra you call him again
99% are not there so just talking to
someone online for few minutes and
giving shada I'm not in favor of that
you understand so there are many dies
who are who do dava online at random
they keep on calling and they take shada
and there videos of that so once I did a
survey I told one one person who was
expert in this. I said do one thing.
Last year all those people you gave
Shaza call them and tell me how many
people are yet Muslims.
So he said I was able to all those are
contacted more than 95%.
Are gone and the 5% which I spoke to who
say they are there they also doubtful.
So
that was not that easy for for someone
to change his full dean overnight. So
it's a process that takes time.
>> Mhm.
So we should not be deceived. We should
not be so much running after how many
shadas you give.
>> So people are more I said take 1%
sufficient.
>> The prophet said it's like a red camel
you know.
>> So many of times people go more on how
many views I've got, how many
subscribers I've got, how many followers
I've got, how many shadas I take. It
should be more of quality rather than
quantity
>> or quantity. And no even if you convince
the problem is like suppose you may go
to a village in Africa it's very easy to
make the full village give shada in
Africa you give them some food they say
shada morning they're Muslim evening
they're Christian next morning again
they're Muslim so this for me you know
you understand now
>> yeah yeah
>> so there are many people who do I'm not
so much I said you do have sayam but I'm
not in favor of s I proper dawa like
okay you have on your television screen
the person is coming and you're
listening for so many you know you can
go back and check reference say that's
the truth you know it's not that you
cannot change your faith will you change
your faith in just 10 minutes of no it's
not possible once in a blue moon okay so
therefore I prefer more dawa should be a
continuous process maybe through friends
or through you know uh on the social
media or on the television on the
satellite so so now for dhawa the
difference should be that I tell lies
now I'm including yourself my advice
would be that certain of your programs
take in high quality. This is camera is
good but good for social media because
we want our work to be saw after we die.
Mhm.
>> So certain programs you record in high
quality film of a good talks. So after
you die you'll get saw. So my thing all
my big programs are I take my own team
when I travel I have 50 people with me
but not for every time
>> when it's a big program so that and we
edit it properly so that even after we
and then we store it on a high quality
>> on 8K and then we downgrade it to HD
>> compressor. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Compressor because original
quality we we maintain in LTO 9. Now LTO
10 has come sorry LTO 10.
>> Do you think this quality is good?
>> I can see the camera. It's good for
social media. Very good.
>> But overall it's not topnotch. Not for
social media. Very good. But see looking
at the camera because my field media is
my field. I'm well versed with Oh, this
is good. Very good for the
>> for social media. Very good.
>> You're surprised you know yourself a lot
more than I thought you would.
>> See our our mic.
>> Yeah.
>> Will our camera stand will be more
expensive than a full equipment. My
camera stand cost me $25,000.
Only my c tripod. How much?
>> $25,000.
>> $25,000
>> US dollar. Only tripod.
>> Not rupee. A dollar.
>> Huh? No. No, no, not dollar,
>> US dollar. Of course, I get a good
discount from all these people because
they know me. So only my stand and my
lens is $150,000. My body is only
$80,000. Then my microphone is also
expensive. You understand? But this is
for high quality. So what we feel so we
call the speakers for a conferences and
they know when we come to Dr. Zakal if
you record he's going to secure
>> the best thing that's important.
>> And when we call them we give them
economic most of them on business. I
said no I travel in economy I can afford
business class I prefer traveling
economy so that and business class is
normally five times more expensive than
economy I can afford it I can afford a
private jet also to fly Allah has given
that wealth
>> but but the problem is that if I travel
in economy I can give four other dies
economically to dawa somewhere else so
we believe in supporting th you
understand now so when we call no th
insist for business class to me other
organizations have business class but to
me they
So we and but we give them good hotels
best fivestar hotels because the cost of
a ticket is more expensive and I know
how to manage I get good discounts
everywhere not because I'm because I say
that I'll give you good business so we
have the best of so our conference is
the most expensive conference in the
world we spend $5 million for one
conference but the rate we get is so
cheap for fivestar hotels for but we
have own policy
I said I don't know any guy who would
guy who so rich to buy business class
himself the demand is different you
understand now so the thing is that I
can afford but I prefer like a lifestyle
for that should be simple my demand
>> less to take from you don't have a lot
of things if you don't have a big home
and Ferraris and all this stuff
>> no one can twist my arm that says this
say that I don't have twist your arm
>> therefore when a person says as I told
you one of the person told me that he
wants to charge for my ticket
>> he wants wants to pay me a million
dollar. $1 million and he'll charge. I
said what? I don't want to lose my
sabah. I'm getting saw from Allah for
giving lecture free.
It is not haram to charge. It's allowed
in Islam. But why should I take a lower
level?
>> So do I have to get rid of my
Rolls-Royce? No, I'm just kidding.
>> Don't see that. See if our talks now
when I give talks there are many
billionaires sitting in the factory. So
I said owning also is not haram
depending how much you earn.
So if you're earning a lot of money and
then if you own a rosa it can come in
mouba category in Islam there are five
categories haram prohibited maku
>> makru discouraged muba that is
optional no plus no negative then sunnah
or mustab
and man is fur in fur you have to do it
if you don't do it you get negative
points like praying salah sunnah if you
do you get plus points if you don't do
no negative points For examp
if you do it then you don't get negative
point but if you don't do it you get
positive point for example standing and
drinking what is sunnah sitting is
better so if I stand and drink it is
makru but no negative point and haram
means if you do it negative point if you
don't do it positive point so rosoy so
If you really earn maybe a few million
dollar a month, see normally when you
are poor, you require at least 20 month
salary to buy a car. The moment you keep
on getting richer, I mean this is my
analysis. If you're a poor man, you
require two years salary to buy a car.
But if you're medium rich, then 5 months
to if you're super rich, no one buys a
car for his uh for his monthly earning
also. Whether it be Bill Gates, they
will be earning million per month. But
the but the car is much cheaper than
that. So it'll be a weekly salary. So
depending how rich you are,
>> can you afford a roso or not?
>> So if you see a monthly salary, if you
can afford, as long as you're paying
zakat and you're giving charity and
doing the far, it becomes muba.
>> But if you can afford and you don't buy,
then you get mustab
you understand what I prefer
giving charity. I'd prefer having a
Toyota and that much whether the because
our Rolls-Roy
cost about 2 million Saudi
that was Ghost
2022 model you know we had the Phantom
we and in Lamborghini we had Urus
>> yours yeah
>> we had and in Bentley we had the uh
Bentega sport
>> Bentega and the And
>> a Bugatti.
>> No, no,
>> no. Bugatti is too expensive. We didn't
buy the Bugatti.
>> Bugatti is the only car we didn't buy.
>> The others we had. So, so we had the
Mayback. So, it's a stinky car anyway.
>> So, a flying spur. Flying spur.
>> Yeah.
>> Then we had the Mayback.
>> So, the other super luxury cars all for
business because during the during the
World Cup in Katar, we thought we'll
make good money. So, that's how we
invested then. And then we had the other
cars, you know, S450. So, a cheapest car
that I had was E200. that was three
times more expensive than my Toyota
Innova.
>> So when I went to meet my daughter in in
Katar which you are studying in HBK I
took the E200 but I was a little bit
uncomfortable as a D having E200. So
then I purchased a Camry for myself.
>> But do you think it's not good for Dies
to roll in style? Cuz nowadays we see
the culture they're attracted to these
type of
>> Correct. Correct. Now you tell me you're
doing dava you're telling me rosy I'm
saying I have a roso I'm not traveling
which is more dava I own a rosoy and I
don't travel in own rosy which is better
for dava
>> I'm telling this not to show off is my
purpose for doing dhava so people ask me
why are you telling this I'm telling
tell the world that even a di can own
all these
>> I'm not telling to show off
>> my main aim is dhava but when I tell
this to those people after money oh dr
deliver.
>> There's a quote from Muhammad Ali
>> where he says that he was braggadocious
and that he was uh a showman because
people wouldn't listen to him without
all the jewelry and fancy things. Is
there any credibility to this statement?
>> See, yes. At one time I do agree like
you know see many people many people
normally I I know many
>> especially American people too.
>> No, no, I know many billionaires in the
world.
>> They're my fans.
I know many billionaires and some of
them cannot travel in a car less than
Rolls-Roy Bentley. They cannot they not
sit in a in a in a Toyota that's against
if they travel in if they go to hotel
they want the presidential suit. So that
is the problem. I said imagine he's
Mskin he's poor means he is recognized
by his rosoid. I'm recognizing my ka
pajama for who is better that means you
require a roid for people to recognize
that you are a billionaire correct for
me my ka pajama people recognize me and
I meet even presidents in this no
problem it should not be obscene you
understand so who is better you're
dependent that means you are dependent
for people to recognize you because you
have a rosa or because you have a big
villa
>> and you're nothing without it
>> without nothing I am for myself I am
what I am
>> they're coming to meet me not my house
not my Rose so the thing is the reason
I'm telling this is just to say normally
I tell lies not to do business they're
difficult Allah has blessed me I'm doing
many businesses so I'm telling this not
to show off to tell that see all this
wealth is there but nothing that is not
my recognition
>> we have we have really these things
that's for my business
but when we call we give him good
facilities except the business class is
too much not that we can't afford it but
we said we don't but we give the best
afford a good discount confident. So
when the dice come for a confident in
Kad they have Mayback and Bentley we let
them drive also they're shocked to give
them a taste and I tell them taste it so
that tomorrow you should not crave for
it
>> let it go out of your head so in I think
in 2014 I took him to Dubai to my friend
and let him drive all the cars that way
and that's what I said that you know we
have studed the best of hotels but when
I travel I have my own policy I never
spend more than $110 per room in a
fivestar hotel anywhere in the world
I've been in USA many times the past
I've stayed in hotels which cost $5,000
a day when the other people call me but
when I pay I have a policy that shoes
should be cheap this so that you know
make your lifestyle simple and that
helped us when I did hijra we were zero
I didn't know anything for one and a
half year and then we started again
Allah has blessed us
have they ever tried to I'm sure you've
got attacks you get the shadow bans the
government
Have they ever tried for your life?
uh to tell you frankly so far except in
the early days when I started dawa there
someone would come with a knife and all
but there's no case of any attack on me
but of course of course I've been on the
list of many things but Allah has been
very has been very kind and
I've been on there many lists
>> but alhamdulillah
>> that's actually what I wanted to ask
like what do you believe are the
consequences that you face for speaking
the truth
in your country
>> I am praying to Allah let me get shada
correct how can I get shada
if I die if someone kills me because I'm
a die that is shada so I pray for that
and there's no higher level of death
than shada I'm not afraid of it but but
natur I don't like to die and not do
anything but I'm doing something good
and if I have to so so I'll leave it to
Allah of course we take precautions we
have security but that is more from the
fans than
I put security but they more from the
fan. I go to commando stay next to you
but that is more from the fans then you
know when you go to the mos they they
mop you and they you know so we have
good but that is because see the people
who are our enemies then you require a
great security to protect but of course
so we have to take care not that we
should not take care of security no
>> do you miss India
>> of course I mainly miss dhava in India
>> because the dhava the way at the
magnitude we used to do there is
something phenomenal and having the
audience there intelligent in Bombay
asking questions and everything you
know. So of course that I miss but here
having a different being in Malaysia is
a different alltogether
opportunity for doing da.
>> What advice would you give to future
dies that want to share the message of
Islam with the world?
uh number one that be as close to the
Quran as soon as possible because there
are some dies who preach to quote the
Quran but when it comes to personal life
they may not be you know they may talk
have to be kind but they may not be kind
to the employees and they may talk
something but they may not so one thing
on speaking on the stage so Allah says
in surah chapter 16 verse number two do
not preach what you do not practice
>> especially those eyes who become more
famous and also that's one thing and
make your life simple
and and uh it's not haram to charge for
doing any activity but I feel leave it
to Allah to do your PR and your
publicity you know so we have never
charged never even I pay for the tea the
uh in my organization as a lump sum even
the tea I have of course I can have tea
now I'm the president of the
organization but I will pay for that
suppose if I give uh a dinner to to my
guest 10 people and if I eat outside in
restaurant I divide the bill by 10 and I
give that so that you know I want to be
you know out of it. So if you make your
life simple
and try and help other people more. So
if Allah has given you there are very
few dies were self-sufficient in the
world today. Very few D
>> very few. So we have a policy of
supporting any D. First we support a
lot. We in a better position before now
it's a different position financially.
So we support others. So imagine if you
Allah has given you maybe you have a
business you're doing very well. So if
you reduce and give it. So imagine what
pleasure you'll be getting
>> that Allah has given me wealth which is
halal from that I'm cutting down. I'm
not telling you to walk and have a cycle
you know walk on the okay travel but
economy of course once you start
traveling in a first class the luxury of
a first class of A380 is so good that
you don't like to travel in a in a
economic class. So that is saying that
once you have tasted that luxury of
trying in a first class suite in A380
especially the way you can have full
blood you can have a shower in it and
then you have the money and yet are
traveling in economic class you want so
the the pleasure you feel is very good
Allah helps with that
>> so make your so people are shocked Dr.
is actually economic class.
You understand that? So the thing is is
that let your life be simple like the
prophet
>> while doing dawa and I agree with you
that when you're talking about glamour
correct rosoy that is the reason I'm
talking about my camera why my camera is
more expensive than Rossy
>> so I'm telling I'm using this wealth for
sake of Allah
>> imagine you understand the the people
that own this camera much less than
people own Rossy so I'm saying this is
my Rolls-Roy my camera M
>> and 18.
>> How many? 18.
>> So this is my rosoy. So then we make it
known to the people that we don't care
for money. We don't care for luxury. We
care for Allah.
>> So then when you say that Allah has
blessed you. I don't know of any D was
on top on the high level. Allah is
blessing me by making me on and I'm not
spending time less than I give less than
1 hour a day
>> for my on my less than 1 hour a day.
Recently recently when I did business in
real estate I did business in real
estate in in in 4 months I hardly
invested about 13.8 8 million dirham
that's about uh less than about $4
million and we made a profit of about
$17 million in four months five times
five times and 51% you calculate my
share was we give $10 million as charity
>> now what won't that get me more
happiness $10 million charity I'm giving
in a matter of four months four to five
months
>> $10 million this house is nothing
$125,000 house so when I give $10
million as v for charity The amount of
happiness it is unbelievable. So what is
better showing off by ro showing off by
this
>> less is more I mean quality is see what
the prophet if you see
so when they know this person he's so
famous he's earning money and yet living
a simple life having a simple watch you
know I get watches I get watches of
Rolex and Philip as gifts this is only
$30 watch not that I can't afford it you
understand we get gifts I got a gift of
Bentley once Bentley car as gift They
sold it and give it in charity. You
understand what I'm saying?
>> Do you think for the D living in luxury
could corrupt their heart?
>> Of course. Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> If you're earning the way I'm earning
it's not haram, but then why not do must
not do something which is encouraging.
>> We spoke about unity especially with the
um right now and how important that is
and I I like the point you made that
even though we have minor differences in
the face of the greater enemy, you
forget your minor differences.
>> Mor major differences.
Forget the major difference. Minor
differ.
>> Major differences.
>> Minor differences. Normal.
>> Yeah.
>> At this point, forget major differences.
>> Okay.
>> Because with Iran, we have major
differences. Not minor differences.
>> What about the major differences? And
that's a great correction.
>> The major differences between the
Christians, for example. I saw there was
a great display of unity where the pope
just was in Algeria and he's walking in
the mazjid and he's saying that maybe we
shouldn't live in fear of the Muslims.
Maybe the Catholics can live in peace
with the Muslims. And he's getting
backlash from the evangelical Christians
in America. These people are saying,
"Well, Trump is saying that the Pope is
weak on crime and the Pope is, you know,
he's depicting himself as Jesus." And
he's saying that the Pope doesn't know
what he's talking about. The Pope
shouldn't speak about the war. He
doesn't know.
>> Is there some sort of unity we could
find with Catholics because the Pope has
made the right efforts to try to show at
least a message of peace.
>> Of course, we should. We should
appreciate that. We should
come to common terms. We should we
should appreciate what is good always
and the best is when we are at peace we
can do better dava
and especially when the pope is talking
something about Islam even though we
know he may have another agenda we
should take it to to our advantage
>> what can his other agenda be
>> sorry no if he has hypothetically he
doesn't have I don't know about this
pope even if he has so we should take
advantage of the commonalities
>> right
>> like when I meet a Christian I say Islam
is the only non-Christian faith
which makes it an article of faith to
believe in Jesus Christ peace be upon
him. No Muslim is a Muslim unless he
believes in Jesus Christ peace be upon
him. We believe that he was one of the
mightiest messengers of God. We believe
that he was born miraculously without
any intervention. We believe that he
gave life to the dead with God's
permission. We believe that he healed
those born blindly with God's
permission. So no, so we have to get the
commonalities.
So even if they talk different, we
should win them is important. That's how
you can to dawa. Dawa can be done more
in the time of peace than a time of war.
That is the reason prophet took
at the time you know they asked for
conditions which were so absurd if you
know the treat of hab you know so
prophet wanted peace and because of that
Islam and what sort of relationship
should I or should people find with
Christian because there is the verse in
the Quran where Allah says in the Quran
never will the Jews and Christians be
accepting of you until become one of
them but it also says
>> that was 120 Yes. And it it also says
that the the true Christians are the
ones that will be the most peaceful
around the Muslims. I don't remember the
exact word he Allah uses, but he says
that the the true Christians will be uh
what is the word
>> when they hear the words of Allah.
>> The closest to the believers are those
who say we are Christians. Christians
and the furthest among them are
>> chapter five. Chapter five.
>> I asked this because the majority of my
audience are Christian. It's not even
Muslim majority. I live in America too
and they resonate with a lot of the the
core things that
>> no I feel you should keep on talking
about the similarities don't talk about
differences for example in your talk if
you make it a point to get this
statement that Islam is the only
non-Christian faith which makes an
article of faith to believe in Jesus
Christ peace be upon it we believe so if
you say these five six sentences it will
bridge gaps irrespective of what type of
Christian there you understand
>> and then of course that's the verse of
the Quran talking about surah bakar
chapter 2 vers 11
that they say you shall never enter
Jenna unless you become a Jew or a
Christian
this is a wishful thinking
produce your proof and one verse of
surah bakar chapter 2 verse 120 which it
says
that they will never accept unless you
become a Christian so these two verses
are what he's saying and the verse in
which he says in surah maida 5:82 that
the closest the the furthest to the
Muslims among the helicab are the Jews
and the closest are those who say that
we are Christians
>> so the furthest one is the Jews the
Quran
>> okay
>> and the closest are the
>> cuz the Jews reject they said as a
messiah
>> they stoned him as he was saying earlier
when he said I and the father are one
>> and what sort of unity will there be and
this is an a question of esquetology but
it says that the Christians and Muslims
will unite against
uh you know the common enemy in the end
of times
>> they'll be the there'll be a time yes
when Muslims unit with them against the
Jews
>> when can we is this going to be again I
I did kind of ask you this earlier
there's no way we can know
>> you don't exactly but the times are
coming
>> Mhm.
>> Yeah. And the other questions I I would
ask about uh Shia and simple things but
I think the important takeaway here that
I can see from your answers is that it's
more more important to focus on
commonalities rather than differences.
>> And it seems like your dawa style is so
effective and I could imagine your talks
with Hindus. you don't focus or try to
be condescending or oh you believe in
this many gods and I'm realizing now I
could also see with Warner too like we
make a lot of errors like you know
probably me more than you but sometimes
you know you could be see all these
ammunition about see I have a talk on
contradiction in the Bible everything
but that's kept for me maybe emergency
like when I had a debate with William
Campbell William Campbell from USA he
come from Pennsylvania he wrote a book
against the Quran the topic was Bible
and Quran in the light of science. So he
wrote a reply to Morris Bukel and for 8
years they used the book against the
Muslim that is there are scientific
errors and he pointed 30 scientific
errors in the Quran and no one replied.
So the Christians used that book that if
Quran has 30 scientific how can be the
word of God. So I had to rebate with
them Chicago. So there of course they
had to and the debate come to attack
then I call mistakes in the Bible
contradictions you know. So, so you
should have this with you
>> ready to go
>> as a last resort,
>> right? It's like a
>> nuclear weapon.
>> You don't want to shoot nuclear weapon.
>> Nuclear weapon
>> nuclear weapon the last have it if you
want to press.
>> And and one more thing they should know
that a lion doesn't have to roar to
prove he's the king of the jungle.
>> A lion doesn't have to roar to prove
he's king of you have to do with. But
when required, of course, I'm with you.
So they know that I can I can rip the
Bible apart. So that is the reason if
you see a video of a Christian
missionaries in UK you say Dr. Zakir he
ripped the Bible apart he blah blah blah
so he spoke against me for one and a
half minute and that video became viral
so that means they should be afraid of
you that these people can do it but we
we deal with love and affair so when
they say oh they speak about Dr. But I
met him he was so humble he speak so
nicely you know so all these people are
against us they do publicity against us
you know he's a ty let them do publicity
but when they meet so that's what they
did did against the prophet the maximum
books written against any human being in
the world is the prophet you so and what
was the most important lesson you
learned from your
the teacher if his name is again
>> ahmed
>> yes what's an important takeaway the
message you could spread from him from
the lessons you learned from him.
>> Ahmed did mashallah he was a man who
only studied till standard six.
>> Only studied what?
>> To the standard six he studied.
>> Okay.
>> After that he dropped dropped out from
school and he challenged the best of
oratoritors in the world. Jimmy Swag at
his time in 1984 8586 Jimmy Swag was
considered to be the best auditor in the
world. His budget was $400 million a
year. He spent more than a million
dollar a day to keep his water and he
debated it with him. Mashallah. So Dad
was simple mashallah coming from poor
family but he had the passion.
So that if you strive in the way of
Allah Allah opens up your pathway. So if
you see history we see life history you
know was simple man and then he rose to
such high levels that everyone would
meet him. We got the king faile award
which is the highest award in the world
and everyone would meet him all the you
know the shake the president and the
kings and at that time he had no
competition there was no d very few dies
in the world now there are mashallah
thousand fight so and then he rose and
then he became so popular people
supported him everything and all so of
course we learned a lot from him because
I spent a lot of time with him you know
we not training under him because I I I
just saw his videos and I and I just
repeated but I met him and spent time
with met his home, he came to my house,
you know, so I learned a lot from him in
>> we talked a lot about the difficulties
with ego and money, fame. What was your
in your career so far? In there's a lot
more years to come. What was the most
difficult test that you had to overcome
to become a successful diet?
I believe when I started doing dawa I
remember in 2008 when we did the second
conference. It was the largest
conference in the world
there were some of the Muslims of a
different sect they complained against
us and at that time the conference was
going to get cancelled. So that was like
you know the biggest jolt in my life for
the my conference you know this main
event in the year spending $5 million
and going to get cancelled at that time
and we didn't know what to do. So I just
went to my room in my cabin. I pray to
all of that. The next day the home
minister son from the capital Delhi
comes and he touches my feet. He says in
my fan I said don't touch the feet. And
then the conflict goes on. Then I
realized that that was just a tip of an
iceberg. What I thought that time was
the biggest problem in my dhava problems
thousand times more came after that. But
my life was cool
>> you know. So I realized that was Allah
training me at that time means the
biggest event you know and $5 million
that stake is going to go and all my all
my everything is all done and going to
be cancelled
>> and all the speakers have come what to
do so that was like something like like
as though my I'm going to die somewhat
similar to that after that things 10
times worse happened many incidents
everywhere in the world but the but the
life became more calm you know just
leave it to Allah strive hard you know
after that I do hijra so when we did
hijra we left all our wealth behind We
left our full organization behind and we
came and then we came to Malaysia and
then you know we were all my full
family. My family has been trained. They
have stayed in the best of hotels in the
world. Seven stars have stepped on the
floor you know I have one son two
daughters and a wife and all of them are
when we go to conferences my son and me
we give lectures to the mix audience and
my wife and my two daughter you know to
ladies. So we always have a ven diagram
you know. Sure
>> that when I you know when I started
doing dawa they said once you get
married so that time I used to spend
maybe about you know 9 hours in dawa so
when I married I married a person who a
da
>> the whole family of dies no of course so
that so then I used to give instead of 8
n hours I give 11 hours
>> so they said when you have children so
then I started Islamic school so then I
started give 14 hours you know in a day
15 hours a day so it's a v diagram so
diagram so that's how mashallah so Allah
has blessed us
>> mhm
>> alhamdulillah so the time have come. So
because of this whole situation that we
should not be dependent on money we've
been on Allah subhanaa tala of course we
need a hijra everything gone but believe
me we didn't none in the family even bat
an island alhamdulillah is for we came
here you know there we had a very good
house a very good beautiful scenario but
this is better
>> of course the house in Mombas is more
expensive being in Bombay but mashallah
so and people mashallah the amount of
respect they gave us they called us
everywhere many people said okay now
you're left Okay, we'll give you $25,000
a month. I don't require that amount.
No, I'll give you $100. They're asking
me. So now you have left everything you
want. You want, I'll give you about you
fund fund the organization, not me. And
yet we kept with the same thing.
Mashallah. So we have maintained with
the same style, that same level. And
Allah has been very kind. The level of
dava increased more. Our our appearance
on the social media increased. And I'm
meeting and trying to solve the problems
all over the world. What's happening in
different parts of the world? We're
trying to, you know, whatever way we can
help. Alhamdulillah.
>> I don't want to keep you too long. I
know m's coming up.
>> I I want to ask you one more because you
you make so many new reverts.
Alhamdulillah. What is the perspective
that in your eyes reverts have that born
Muslims don't have? Is there a different
lens that reverts see Islam through?
>> Yes. When the the advantage of see there
are two types of revert. One revert has
become a revert maybe because of love
marriage. Okay.
Many of time they marry they become
Muslim only because they loved a Muslim
girl but then they become more
practicing than Muslim many times and
sometime they remain
>> those rewards I've studied and I've you
know got impressed and then
alhamdulillah
one of the major reason is to you know
>> the most important
>> one is
>> and and believing that all Muslims are
equal
of course when they come they may find
some differences in the teaching other
than the practices you You know
depending on which country takes up
Islam but I always say that when a
person becomes a reward wherever
possible let one Muslim be like a family
member like for example reward comes he
may have difficulties going to pray
going alone he's a new person he may not
be have support from the family there
should be one person like if he's a gent
let there be a Muslim brother if it's a
female let the Muslim sister be with
them at least for 6 months as the family
member that mean you can call them 24/7
so at least he's comfortable and he sees
atmosphere and you and then the
organization is there just giving sh and
leaving them then we go back so the
difference that I find that the person
who accept Islam on average is a better
practicing Muslim than a person who
average Muslim
>> average
if you take an average Muslim from India
an average revert who becomes a revert
he is more practicing than average
Muslim
there may be Some words are bad. Some
words are very good but average because
they have chosen Islam by choice.
>> What was your favorite moment in Da like
from your career of Dawa? What was your
favorite the most memorable moment
you've had? Oh
>> there are there are many I cannot choose
as
>> okay well I give the top two top three
me when people ask questions where your
mind goes blank and Allah gives you the
answer
and some questions we wonder what is the
answer and then I get up and say brother
ask a good question in my heart I don't
know the answer you know that's my style
so when a brother ask a good question
give me more time to you know so I
brother ask a good question and I don't
know the answer and then repeat the
question I don't know the answer and
then Allah gives the And then
>> oh okay
>> so that is like you know so mainly when
someone asks me a very difficult
question which normally people can't
answer and then Allah give me the answer
that is the time when I so much so so
when I get the question is even now
online diff then I find the answer and
then the answer I find is very logical
so that the pleasure that I get is
phenomenal
>> can we get uh one brother asked a very
good question because you know that's a
name is all over the world to give you
the answer only
in Dubai there's a person by the name of
Rahul so he told that you know and this
person was Hindu he says in public that
I know more about Islam than my
management where I've got MBA degree
from UK and he says that I've read many
tapas of the Quran when the first
revelation was given to prophet Muhammad
the archangel Gabriel Archangel Gabriel
said Quran he's saying he's Hindu
good English. He said Ira read and the
prophet said I cannot read. His question
is that when when the archangel Gabriel
told prophet Mohammed Ikra read what did
he show him? Where is that thing he
showed him? Is it in the museum? Is it
in top cap museum? Is it in Saudi
Arabia? What did he show him and where
is it now? It's not mentioned anywhere
in the Quran or so in any taps. What did
Archangel Gabriel show Prophet Muhammad
and what he showed him? Where is it
present now? you should tell me this.
So I said brother asked a good question
and I don't know the answer and I repeat
the question and then I said uh that
brother do you know Japanese? He said
no. I said did I show you something that
you said you don't know Japanese
and he tried to class and then he said
afterwards so sometimes after you know
it is more of logic
whether do you know Japanese he said no
I said did I show you something in
Japanese and he said no. So of course so
there are many of the questions are more
of you know logic and mantik you know
>> rather than knowledge
>> so that comes with practice you know of
course Allah's help is the most
important and of course when we were
kids we had milestone I want to get a
good medal in sport I want to give a
talk of with so I told you know these
milestones are actually irrelevant when
we were kids it was there you know so
when I entered I said oh sh 12,000 I
want to give give a talk to 12,000
people live that was my aim
and now Allah has blessed us to give
more than more than a million people but
that is not the target at all
>> so so what should the intention be of
the di like it's to please Allah that's
the main intent
>> yes enter Jenna please Allah and enter
Jennah please Allah that's more
important so pleasing Allah is more
important than you know of course there
are there are world world
uh milestones
Like shad 12,000 was 12,000. Oh shad got
the king fell award. Even I want to get
king fel award.
What is king fell award? Nothing at that
time because shid got king fell award.
Oh oh oh shake. Oh sh got so much
donation
at that time. Oh you got one gift $2
million donation that is peanut. So you
know so whatever Dav was like like an
ideal you know for for us you know
whatever he did was so largest audience
12,000 and see Allah blessed us with 1
billion where is 12,000 is 1 million
king award we got award we got the world
award we got toward
>> 1 million people in the audience
>> life life sitting
>> that's nuts how do you even fit an arena
that big
>> no no opening around 150 acres
>> at a big field or something
>> yeah they're sitting on the ground there
were chairs were only about maybe 50
100,000 more 50,000 chairs 50,000
remaining on the ground in the field
a million people
>> a million people live actually I have a
question since like all of you guys are
so famous and stuff and my mom is also
like a very big fan of Zak do you guys
like get a lot of like marriage
proposals and stuff like that
>> what proposal
>> marriage proposal
>> me
>> oh you don't want to have that question
to me of course you bearing but we happy
with the wife that I've got you know
this is the favorite pastime in the Gulf
country that why don't you have a second
wife it's a favorite pastime when you go
in the Gulf country then fa
the
favorite pastime of saying why don't you
have a second wife so I being a debater
I give the reply that the prophet
sallall alaihi wasallam till his first
wife Khijah may Allah be pleased with
her till that time she was alive he did
not marry second I have my khijah with
me. If you don't have your khijah, it's
your problem.
>> So sunnah is after your first wife who
the best wife dies then you get married.
That's the sunnah. I mean of course you
can I'm not saying no to but I'm still
debating. So I said if you see the
lifestyle of the prophet the first wife
was there after the first wife died he
married and the first wife was elder
than the prophet my wife was elder by
about 2 three weeks. So I said I'm doing
the sun. married a wife with elder than
me and you know so we all are doing all
just they said to win doctor with Dr. I
can even imp
>> if we're supposed to follow Quran sunna
completely
>> technically it's suna to marry nine
wives why is this one separate
>> no sorry you have to understand certain
things what was first for the prophet is
not first for us
>> so technically suna I I understand
>> no no no I'll I'll come to certain
things what the prophet did you cannot
do there's a verse in the Quran in surah
azab 33 51 52- 53 which says for the
prophet after this you cannot marry
anyone except what a right hand
possesses and what you can marry others
cannot marry. So these are mentioned in
the Quran
>> you know for example the prophet had to
hij and all so for us it is for for the
prophet he was given the permission and
why I've given a full talk on that
because he did for people to come closer
to each other for for Islam to spread so
all his all his marriages like had some
of the other reason all the marriages
were wives
>> they were widows and they were widows
friends
>> and he had only one virgin wad only one
virgin
>> and that was so to bring relationship
with the closest Abuakar may Allah be
pleased. You understand? So all had some
reason and logical reason because she
was young after he died she was one of
the greatest lady scholars at that time
>> of hadith.
So the amount of hadith she narrated you
know and she taught 88 scholars. So that
reason for everything.
>> Mhm. Some people say I read online that
although you don't claim to follow any
school of thought and which is perfect.
I loved your answer. They say that you
follow the Salafi school of thought. See
one thing is there that you know those
who love me if they're jamaati Islami
they call me jamati they love me they're
tabliki they call me tabliki the salafi
they call me sali to be very straight to
be a very frank answer among the schools
of thought I respect all of them but the
closest to Quran sunnah would be the
salaf
but
>> I found that to be true as well
>> true any logical person comes
>> see you have to understand the marks the
difference mean you may give one 94
marks the other 95 n that's
It's not that one is 40 and 1. No, no,
no. According to me, if you do a proper
survey, it will be between 92 and 98 all
of them. You understand? So, but but
there are some people unfortunately that
they they so if you meet the Salafi
scholars, they are great. But those who
pass from these institution they super
salafi they do takir
oh he I would go to ja that is the
problem. So you have more problem
sometimes in the they feel they are they
feel they're superior
>> you understand so that is the problem.
>> Mhm. So if you meet the real scholars
the salafi scholars in in Saudi Arabia
oh they're too good scholars are very
few but those who go to the institution
and oh we are only right all the others
are the problem. The moment you say I'm
only right, I say I'm also right. I'm
also right means you may be right, maybe
wrong. We'll discuss tomorrow. I am. But
when you say I'm only right mean the
others are wrong.
>> Right?
>> So this is the problem that that and now
when you find in the English dies of
course there are more selfies coming up.
M in the English it's good but then you
have to be careful some are super
selfies also you know. So what they do
they keep on taking out those people who
try to get the other Muslims together.
they speak against them and they're
saying the kafit so they'll pick up all
the people on the pitch TV the speakers
who are salafies but they want to get
all together so these super usually
speak against them oh this person is a
cafe he's not a scholar he's not
following Quran so this is a trend that
has come
to my way always been that we try to get
the people together like when I go to
Pakistan Pakistan has a lot of different
sides but I try to get them together.
>> No, we have to stop. Sorry, brother. We
have to stop for very
>> What time is
>> Oh, it's just like about 4 5 minutes. 5
minutes.
>> No, no. It is 7:20. 7:20.
>> 7:24, I think.
>> 10 minutes.
>> No, it's quite some time. Is it? I mean,
we can speak after that if you want. No
problem.
>> Also, you have a lot of energy.
>> No, I can keep going. 7:20 is Mr.
>> If you want we can speak after if you
have time no problem speak
>> I'm available sorry no problem Ramadan
>> except I will not stop for salah salah
should not miss no problem so today
>> three so if you want to speak I'm
>> I want to ask you about HRA because uh
I've been traveling a lot you said
earlier that you hadn't seen Bazi yet I
love this place I love Malaysia so much
has been a fantastic do hijra. He said,
>> "What was that?"
>> You said you're interested in doing
hijra.
>> Yes. But the apprehension is that the
United States is where all the
propaganda starts and where it's most
impactful.
>> This is where wars begin in this place.
This is where all the lies are spread.
This is where the Muslims are demonized
and called terrorists. And
>> it's beneficial I find and Warner finds
as well to be within this
within all
the lies that ecosystem where all the
enemies are trying to uh bring us down.
So I'm essentially putting off my HRA
because I know that it's effective to be
there. Is that just cop? Is there any
sense to that? Is that
>> you you're right. Partly right partly
right. That's my partly right. No, this
this was the uh 10 minutes before the
problem.
>> Okay. So the thing is that you're partly
right but one thing you have to realize
that number one when when there's a
problem in the aeroplane you know when
the when the level goes down the pilot
says first put the mask on yourself
and then on your child correct
>> when there is atmosphere problem or the
oxygen problem in the plane and the mask
fall what you do say I'll first save my
son no you have to first put the mask on
say why if you are alive will you save
him correct You understand the logic?
>> Mhm.
>> You understand the logic? Now means if
there is a problem of danger and if you
have your own child
who's 5 years old, the pilot says first
put the mask on yourself
>> and then you put the mask on the child.
>> Why? If you try and put the mask on the
child, by the time you will not be able
to get the oxygen, you may die. So first
you save yourself and then others.
There's a verse in the Quran in surah ch
4 verse number 97 that when the angels
of death come and ask you how were you
in the world and they will say that we
were in in total submission and uh uh
the
what is the word that's used uh the
English word I forgot chapter 4 97 that
we have been in operation
huh and subjugation
So the angel replies, "Isn't the world
of Allah big enough for you to migrate?"
Now this context is when this verse was
revealed when the Sabas were in Makkah
and when the majority of people in
Makkah were non-Muslims. So in a city
like Makkah which is the holy city a
verse was revealed and the Sabbath had
to migrate out of the when when the
prophet had to Medina there were some
Muslim sabas who were in Makkah. So the
verse was revealed that you you don't
have to stay where the majority are
non-Muslims to safeguard yourself and
then the verse continues except those
who are weak who are old men and women
who cannot migrate Allah will forgive
them that means it becomes fur for you
to migrate
if you're living in a majority of a
non-Muslim country. Now the main logic
of this is I know many Muslim dies like
for example Mhammad Salah many of them
who migrated to US they got their
passport somewhere on the verge of and
they came back because they said when we
as children we can't give guarantee I've
been to America several times we cannot
give guarantee for your children see now
there is fa everywhere in the world
including including here I'm not saying
no everywhere but the levels differ
even in Malaysia there is even in India
there is but in America it's glaring
the opportunity you see no
>> it's bad it's getting really bad
>> no it's too much so the level of them
may be 90% other place 70% so tomorrow
something happens to your children
you're responsible so one thing is you
have to safeguard yourself first and
regarding dawa it may be correct maybe
100 years back now you are doing dawa to
America even I'm doing dawa to America
it's correct I'm not I'm not I'm not
saying I'm doing more than you but I've
got a great following even in America
correct I've got following in Europe
sort off my 200 million. There are
millions even there. I'm doing the work.
You don't have to be there. Of course,
being there is beneficial. I'm not
saying no. But first, you have to
safeguard yourself and your family.
>> Yeah.
>> So now the chances the way the world is
going now, now you cannot even when you
when your child is born, you cannot
mention the gender of your child.
Correct? Let the child decide when they
grow up. What's happening now? LGBT the
way it's going on. The way attacks on
Islam. So now the Islamic ruling is you
have to stay in a Muslim majority
country. You have to migrate. That is
the Islamic ruling. Unless you're weak
or you don't have capacity to migrate
unless you know so and then the way
secondary first save yourself. What do
you know tomorrow what will happen to
me? You understand now? So you and your
family you may have your children you
understand now. So I would advise always
that okay have some of your uh roots
over there whatever is there but
migrating is best and according to me
the best of the worst country or the
best available country would be Malaysia
all the pros and cons
>> a lot of great things about Malaysia I
see why you made
>> and especially Putya there's a world of
a difference between colum and kalumpur
has a lot of oppunityity yeah mah
>> not that bad compared to America
>> I'm from New York like Sorry,
>> I'm from New York. Like this is nothing
compared to
>> nothing.
See on the list Malaysia also quite high
but certain cities Kalur is penang
>> I love I quite love Kalumpur
has got the fash so the red light are
also so which is not there here. Yeah,
>> you understand it's good but not as good
as
>> right
>> you know because there there are 45%
Chinese and Muslims are 42% you
understand here the Muslims are more
than more than 95% here
>> what's the percentage of Muslims here
>> more than 95 some say 97 some say 98%
>> 98% here in in
>> Can you show them the view
>> in this in this whole of Malaysia 65%
>> whole of Malaysia 65 except for two
cities
>> except for two cities which will not be
fully Sharia compliant is Kolanur and
Pinang
>> because there the Muslims are not in
majority I mean very frankly correct but
here it's very quite economical very
cheap see the beauty you know no
nightclub you know hard rock wanted to
open a branch here
>> and put hard rock you know okay you can
open but no music no alcohol no
alcohol so how can you know so so here
they have got some you know
alhamdulillah
>> so so that way
>> it's kind of like shar and Dubai.
>> Yes, you are right.
>> Yes. Yes. Yes.
But but this right perfect it's very
good you you can stay away from it but
you know here are some things anyway
that's not but so so therefore I I did
stay for first I used to come for giving
lecture the first time I came was 1996
went go but then when I had to stay I
stayed for a few weeks in maybe a month
in columa then I came here and I as the
persona which is the best view he said
this apartment. So I said, "Okay, help
him."
>> They made a great choice,
>> huh?
>> They made a great choice here.
>> Uh, so then we saw the view is the best.
So we took this and that's how we went.
>> I just noticed your library over here
too.
>> No, this is just maybe 2% of my library.
>> Just 2%.
>> The main thing was in Bombay. We bought
half of it which is another apartment.
The full
all the books are stored in one
apartment. The one apartment has become
a store room. We have got six apartments
here.
>> Oh, so there's apartment just for the
books.
>> Books and some tapes I think.
>> Oh, okay.
>> Books and tapes. myself.
>> So that is a rented apartment. The
others of course we purchasing this
apartment here. So that's my son and
here one apartment studio and one is for
my staff and
>> now the new joke is
>> and two apartments are for two
apartments for D. If any d come they put
the free same view there's the apartment
below same view that men for d any can
come and stay a completely
>> zakan's library
>> his basement
>> they have two apartments for dive
>> the one that is down immediately there's
the best view you can see the pudra
mosque as well as this mos and even
below 1920 we have two apartments for
dive
>> this is just a
>> this is ether haram this is the special
>> we should have brought something
>> this special ether that is put on the
Cabba on the kisvah.
>> This you can't buy it with money. You
cannot buy it with money. This is the
one that you put on the on the black
cloth.
>> Yeah.
>> Of the cabba and so this is a special
that we so this is not available.
>> Thank you so much.
>> So this is just a small gift from my
and that's for you as well.
>> And this is this is original that put on
the for the
mal. It's a mixture. So this made by one
of my friends for
>> Oh, it smells good.
>> You can just turn it off.
>> Thank you so much.
>> I'll just if you want to
>> look at the
>> kiss. So you can't buy
>> Yeah, I can't buy this. They make
especially for the for the cloth of the
>> I'm going to put on my clothes.
>> Yeah, you just put just put on this
>> the same thing.
>> This is a different bottle.
the same thing but this is
>> the special thing which you know so if
you've been to Haram often and you go
close to the kissa you'll get the same
>> it's a little hard to get over there now
people
yes yes unless you get some special
permission to go inside the car also
>> oh it even says here Dr.
Zach Nike
>> exquisitly yours. This perfume is not
available for sale anywhere in the
world.
>> Wow. That's right. Look at that.
>> So you know when we used to meet the
VIPs what to give what bunny cannot buy.
So this is what you can buy.
>> So this is something which money cannot
buy. When we meet VIP they can buy
anything.
>> So this thing money cannot buy.
>> So if I put it on eBay I'm going to make
a lot.
>> Sorry.
>> Can I take it back then?
>> What they say? I was saying
>> eBay and make a lot of money.
No, there was a time you know there was
a time that I gave a cloth of kaban
madina to one a friend said can I sell
it and give I said yes. So he sold it a
very high price and he gave that money
for donation. I said good
cloth of that and
>> thank you so much
>> it's a pleasure inshallah
I
>> appreciate it.
>> Do you have the contacts?
>> Thank you so much. It was an absolute
pleasure getting the chance to speak to
you. I've been looking forward to this
for several days. I hope that the
questions were
>> were good and I hope you enjoyed the
conversation.
>> If you can give a copy of that if you
don't mind.
>> Absolutely.
>> Of the so that we can
>> Yeah, absolutely.
>> If we can give a copy of the recording.
>> Well, it's not film quality $25,000. No
problem. This tripod's about $50, not
$25,000.
>> No problem. No problem. No problem.
>> But next time
>> for social media, it'll be fine. So, we
can
>> You mind if we take a Let's take a photo
ways.
>> Sure. Let's take all one and then all of
us.
>> Yeah.
>> And I think he he wants one on his phone
as well.
>> Yeah.
>> The only expensive thing I have is this
for
>> That's a nice case right there. M.
>> No, no. We get more expensive mobiles
also. You know the Oh,
>> you do?
>> Virtue. What? Virtue is more expensive.
>> You know what? You know,
>> virtue phone.
>> Virtue phone. You don't know
>> iPhone?
>> No. No. iPhone is the best normal phone,
but the most expensive mobile is worth.
You don't know.
>> No.
>> Because half a million dollar and more.
>> You don't know.
>> I thought you was half a million.
>> No, not this. So, this that phone I got
gifted. I gave it away to somebody else.
So, this is the only expensive thing I
keep because for technology and for
dava.
>> The second last one. Last one.
>> Come on in. I didn't get a chance to say
Salam Lego with you either, bro.
>> You okay?
>> There's like 10 cameras.
>> What your phone is a stat?
1 2 3.
>> Okay, Mag.
for your time. My
>> pleasure.
I want to
>> ego keeps getting
>> mogged.
The opportunity.
>> Yes, sir.
>> They're leaving to Jakarta tomorrow.
>> Tomorrow.
>> They're having some talks. Yeah.
Yeah, actually
>> it's more like a podcast recording.
>> Someone had the loudest camera of all
time.
>> What is that camera? I had that one
before. Is that a cannon?
>> No, someone that was like beeping in the
back.
>> Oh, no. I think
>> it was the guy who ran up on you.
ready for
>> that's an aggressive alarm for the for
prayer. You make sure you don't miss the
prayer.
>> No in Jamaat. No
one very rare but but I always jam but
that's one of the reason I feel praying
in jamad is a fur
>> not praying praying in jamaat in the
mosque the difference of
but I believe that if you miss in jama
when I come here
>> unless you're traveling
>> which I am so technically I can skip
mood right
>> no you can join don't skip you cannot
skip
>> but is I can do both
>> yes you can join
>> soisha you can join you can join the
together you have that delivery So when
you travel it different and you don't
have to read the sunnah.
>> Well, this is a weird one because
technically I'm always traveling cuz I
have uh I live in Miami and New York and
I'm always abroad.
>> Okay, you can follow it.
>> When you're driving, you have two
options. Either pray in the or you can
join both options.
>> I prefer the the prayer. Do you want to
head down to go to the masid?
What time is the
go?